How I met your mother is the reason that I fell in love with my partner, not the only reason obviously he's amazing but when we first started dating we were long distance and we were looking for something we could do together specifically every night so we started watching how I met your mother cuz we were both huge fans and lo and behold not long after that we discovered there was the how we made your mother podcast so we started listening to the episodes together and then we would watch the episode of television and then at night when we had a chance to finally connect after our long separate days, all the way across the United States from each other.
我如何遇见你母亲是我爱上我的伴侣的原因，显然不是他很棒的唯一原因，但当我们第一次开始约会时，我们距离很远，我们正在寻找每天晚上可以一起做的事情，所以我们开始观看我是如何遇见你母亲的，因为我们都是超级粉丝，你瞧，不久之后我们发现了我们如何制作你母亲的播客，所以我们开始一起听剧集，然后我们会看电视节目，然后在晚上，当我们有机会最终联系时在我们漫长的分开的日子之后，我们一路穿越美国。
We would talk about our favorite parts of the episode and comment on the podcast as well.
我们会讨论这一集中我们最喜欢的部分，并对播客进行评论。
And then we are finally at a year today.
今天我们终于迎来一周年了。
Today's our anniversary of a year together, and we're looking at closing the distance.
今天是我们在一起一周年的纪念日，我们正在考虑缩短距离。
And I'm so excited both to have this podcast to continue watching together and also to be able to watch the show in person from our home that we are going to make together.
我很高兴能够继续一起观看这个播客，并且能够亲自在家里观看我们将一起制作的节目。
And I am so in love and so happy.
我是如此相爱，如此幸福。
And this show and this podcast are a big part of why our relationship is so strong today because we have such common interests and we're just about to start watching the trilogy again together as well.
这个节目和这个播客是我们今天关系如此牢固的一个重要原因，因为我们有如此共同的兴趣，而且我们也即将开始再次一起观看三部曲。
So we're going to trill it up.
所以我们要让它颤音起来。
So we appreciate you and all that you do to help connect all the the How I Met Your Mother fans worldwide, including two people who fell in love together while watching How I Met Your Mother.
因此，我们感谢您以及您为帮助连接全世界所有《老爸老妈的浪漫史》粉丝所做的一切，包括在观看《老爸老妈浪漫史》时相爱的两个人。
Thank you all.
谢谢大家。
I'm alone in New York City when I see.
当我看到这一点时，我独自一人在纽约。
You just permit me to tell you every city.
你只要允许我告诉你每个城市就可以了。
Welcome to How We Made Your Mother.
欢迎收看《我们如何成就了你的母亲》。
I'm Josh Radner.
我是乔什·拉德纳。
I'm here with my friend Craig Thomas.
我和我的朋友克雷格·托马斯在这里。
Hey, Craig.
嘿，克雷格。
Hey, Josh.
嘿，乔什。
Craig, you know how people who kind of make business matches, they get a cut of it?
克雷格，你知道那些进行商业匹配的人如何从中分一杯羹吗？
Uh-huh.
嗯嗯。
We make relationship matches like there's no cut of it.
我们的关系匹配就像没有任何剪裁一样。
I mean, maybe it's karma like good karma for us It's the good feeling we have from hearing that message.
我的意思是，也许这对我们来说就像善业一样，这是我们听到这个消息后的良好感觉。
God.
上帝。
When did you become so commercialized Josh?
乔什，你什么时候变得如此商业化了？
I don't like this side of you But what a great story.
我不喜欢你的这一面，但这真是一个很棒的故事。
Thanks for sharing that lovely.
感谢分享如此可爱。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Yeah, that's amazing I mean, that's all we're doing Craig is we're watching these episodes and we're connecting Exactly and we get to bring in other connections.
是的，这太棒了，我的意思是，克雷格，我们所做的就是我们正在观看这些剧集，我们正在准确地建立联系，并且我们可以引入其他联系。
Do you see where I'm going with this we get Bring it now.
你明白我要说什么了吗？我们现在就把它带来。
Okay.
好的。
She's right here on the screen.
她就在屏幕上。
What are you talking about?
你在说什么？
No, we just were talking to her a second ago.
不，我们刚刚在和她说话。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
No, she's a producer.
不，她是制片人。
Ladies and gentlemen, we're just diving right into it.
女士们先生们，我们刚刚开始深入探讨。
We haven't said a word about even what episode we're talking about.
我们甚至没有说我们正在谈论哪一集。
We're talking about the episode, how I met everyone else written by an amazing writer and an amazing human being who was on how much mothers three seasons wrote a bunch of great stuff.
我们正在谈论这一集，我如何认识由一位出色的作家和一位出色的人所写的其他人，他在《母亲们》的三季中写了一堆很棒的东西。
We've been trying to get her on here since early season two.
从第二季初期开始，我们就一直在努力让她加入进来。
Our schedules all finally lined up.
我们的日程终于都排好了。
The great Gloria Calderon Colin is here with us.
伟大的格洛丽亚·卡尔德隆·科林和我们在一起。
Gloria in the house.
格洛丽亚在屋里。
How are you?
你好吗？
I'm so good, guys.
我很好，伙计们。
This is such a joy to get to sit with you guys and talk about this.
很高兴能和你们坐在一起谈论这个问题。
Man, Gloria, when Craig told me that you only wrote on the first three seasons, I was like, that's wrong.
伙计，格洛丽亚，当克雷格告诉我你只写了前三季时，我想，这是错误的。
My memory of, is it you were like on seven or eight seasons?
我的记忆里，你是七八季的样子吗？
GLOW has an outsized impact.
GLOW 具有巨大的影响力。
Well, I came back and acted in season five.
好吧，我回来出演了第五季。
You did?
你做到了吗？
Oh, that's right.
哦，是这样。
That's right.
这是正确的。
But you also like, I know you and Kobe were really close.
但你也喜欢，我知道你和科比非常亲密。
but also like you were at, you were at a lot of the parties, a lot of fundraisers that Craig threw, like you stayed very much in the family.
但也像你参加的那样，你参加了克雷格举办的很多聚会和筹款活动，就像你非常留在家里一样。
Part of the fam, part of the fam, and went on to create the one day at a time reboot and additional 100 other great things.
是家庭的一部分，是家庭的一部分，并继续创造了一天一次的重启和另外 100 件其他伟大的事情。
You were a very accomplished, amazing writer.
你是一位非常有成就、令人惊叹的作家。
We were so lucky to have you on the show.
我们很幸运能邀请您参加演出。
And this episode so holds up.
这一集如此成立。
I love, I really love this episode.
我爱，我真的很喜欢这一集。
Well, why would it say, for me, this is like a top tenor, like all time.
好吧，为什么会说，对我来说，这就像一个顶级男高音，就像所有时间一样。
like I really think this episode is like all guns firing.
就像我真的认为这一集就像所有枪声一样。
Like it's so good to me.
好像对我太好了。
It's so much of the stuff that made the show great in terms of like storytelling and like the blah blah of it all was so fun.
有太多的东西让这部剧在讲故事方面变得很棒，而且这一切都很有趣。
I remember when we were talking about that because there was one version where like, oh let's make it like he doesn't remember the color of her dress and the dress changes.
我记得当我们谈论这个问题时，因为有一个版本，哦，让我们假装他不记得她衣服的颜色和衣服的变化。
And we were like, there were a bunch of different things and then somebody landed on, I don't remember who landed on.
我们就像，有很多不同的东西，然后有人登陆，我不记得是谁登陆了。
Let's make her name blah blah.
让我们给她取个名字吧，巴拉巴拉。
And that just, it's such a funny one.
这真是太有趣了。
It's so only the idea that it's a story being told 25 years in the future and you forget people's names.
这只是一个想法，这是一个在 25 年后讲述的故事，而你忘记了人们的名字。
You don't like, you don't remember.
你不喜欢，你不记得。
And that was one of my favorite uses of the unreliable narrator, the middle-aged brain narrator, that we are on now that age and we are definitely forgetting people's names.
这是我最喜欢的不可靠叙述者的用途之一，中年大脑叙述者，我们现在处于那个时代，我们肯定会忘记人们的名字。
25 years ago.
25年前。
Well, it's also, it's so smart because it reminds you this is a story being told.
嗯，它也很聪明，因为它提醒你这是一个正在讲述的故事。
Yes.
是的。
And that like, keep a little asterisk by all these details because this is like a fallible memory telling me.
就像，在所有这些细节上加一个星号，因为这就像一个错误的记忆告诉我的。
This is not a documentary.
这不是一部纪录片。
This is a human fallible human memory.
这是人类易犯错误的人类记忆。
You know, my, a friend of mine calls fire channel one, which I think is so funny.
你知道，我的一个朋友称消防通道为一，我认为这很有趣。
Like it's the first channel that people gather around.
就像这是人们聚集的第一个频道。
And there's something about this episode.
这集有一些事情。
Like just fire on a cave.
就像山洞里着火一样。
Fire on a cave and it's channel one.
洞穴着火，它是第一通道。
I remember like that.
我记得是这样的。
It's the first channel that humans watched.
这是人类观看的第一个频道。
But there's something about booth episodes.
但有一些关于展位的情节。
Like this is a booth episode.
就像这是一个摊位情节。
This is like an actual- This is the fair side.
这就像真实的——这是公平的一面。
And it feels like they're gathered around a campfire telling tales.
感觉就像他们聚集在篝火旁讲故事。
The oral tradition.
口头传统。
It really does have that feeling.
确实有这种感觉。
This one, Josh and I talk about like, it's fun going back and analyzing what makes a good how much mother episode.
乔什和我谈到这一集，回顾并分析什么才是一部好的《母亲》剧集是很有趣的。
And sometimes what makes a less good how much mother episode.
有时，母亲的插曲有多不好。
The idea of filling in the lore, I think Josh coined that phrase.
填充传说的想法，我认为乔什创造了这个短语。
This is the epitome of the filling in the lore episode.
这就是传说中填充的缩影。
This is just everyone's origin story, how every single person that is taking the title of the series and now turning it back on all the characters and taking it away from is who's the mother, who's the mother?
这只是每个人的起源故事，如何每个人都获得了该系列的标题，现在将其转回到所有角色并将其从谁身上夺走，谁是母亲，谁是母亲？
How did these people, what was their origin story on what they made it?
这些人是怎么做的，他们的起源故事是什么？
And also like the fun of remembering the Barney Met Ted moments before.
也喜欢记住巴尼遇见泰德之前的那一刻的乐趣。
Right, and filling in that pilot scene.
对了，补充一下试播场景。
We would re-shot that pilot scene.
我们会重新拍摄试播场景。
Yeah.
是的。
And showed you were gonna say in the pilot, like weren't you just talking to me at the urinal or something like this?
并表明你会在试播集中说，你不是刚刚在小便池里跟我说话吗？
Yeah, at the urinal.
是的，在小便池边。
And now with three seasons later, two seasons later we get to show that scene.
现在，三个赛季之后，两个赛季之后，我们可以展示那个场景。
That is the most fun thing when you actually get to fill in those like little verbal moments, like the bunk beds from the pilot became a scene in season two.
当你真正填补那些小小的言语时刻时，这是最有趣的事情，就像飞行员的双层床成为第二季中的一个场景。
Yeah.
是的。
the top-notch moves and it's also fun to see that uh wow Ted uh his hair was longer in uh one of those scenes that they had the pilot one.
一流的动作，而且很有趣的是，在试播集的其中一个场景中，看到特德的头发更长了。
It's not all again non-documentary.
这不再是非纪录片了。
Yeah yeah it's he remembered it differently the second time.
是的，是的，第二次他的记忆有所不同。
Yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah but there there's so much fun I mean this must have been well let's real quick uh uh Alec tell us when this episode aired we just like to oh wow this makes us feel a little every week every time that Glug are ready to be bummed out.
是的，是的，是的，是的，但是有很多乐趣，我的意思是，这一定很好，让我们快点，呃，亚历克告诉我们，当这一集播出时，我们只是想哦，哇，这让我们每周都会感到一点，每次 Glug 都准备好沮丧了。
Oh, God.
哦，上帝。
1873, it was March of 1873.
1873年，那是1873年3月。
This episode originally aired on October 22nd of 2007.
本集最初于2007年10月22日播出。
Oh, okay.
哦好的。
Oh, boy.
哦，男孩。
Did they have TVs in them?
他们里面有电视吗？
Wow.
哇。
I know.
我知道。
The honeymooners was our lead.
蜜月夫妇是我们的主角。
Wait, Gloria, I often ask Craig to do this, but the title is pretty self-explanatory, but can you just give us like a little summary of this?
等等，格洛丽亚，我经常要求克雷格这样做，但标题是不言自明的，但你能给我们做一点总结吗？
What's the log line when you say, I guess what is kind of stuff?
当你说“我猜是什么东西”时，日志行是什么？
I've had everyone else.
我已经拥有了其他人。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
And this is the story of how these group of friends all got to meet one another.
这就是这群朋友如何相遇的故事。
They're first encounter of one another.
他们是第一次见面。
You get, you get Marshall and Barney, you get Robin and Ted's repeat of that moment told through Bla Bla's eyes.
你得到，你得到马歇尔和巴尼，你得到罗宾和泰德通过布拉布拉的眼睛讲述的那一刻的重复。
You get, oh my gosh, Ted and Lily, and then we find out it's, it wasn't actually, they actually did meet the second time.
你会发现，天哪，泰德和莉莉，然后我们发现，实际上不是，他们确实第二次见面了。
Well, you get Marshall and Ted, which is also a callback to, did he already say in an earlier episode I thought you were the Dean?
好吧，你得到了马歇尔和泰德，这也是对他在之前的一集中说过我以为你是院长了吗？
I feel like that was a callback.
我感觉那是一个回调。
I feel like that was another time where there was like a throwaway line that we then showed the scene of.
我觉得那是另一个时间，就像我们随后展示的场景一样，有一条一次性的台词。
I think that's right.
我认为这是对的。
Yeah.
是的。
No, it's really like you took every character and you drew lines to everyone.
不，这真的就像你拿走了每个角色，并为每个人画了界限。
Everyone had lines.
每个人都有台词。
We have the actual hot crazy line.
我们有真正的热疯狂线。
It was, there's a lot in this app.
是的，这个应用程序中有很多东西。
There's a lot in this app.
这个应用程序中有很多内容。
The sandwiches, the introduction of the sandwiches.
三明治，三明治的介绍。
The introduction of the sandwiches.
三明治的介绍。
Advent of sandwiches, marijuana, that is, this is the, that became a series, long runner, the people close.
三明治、大麻的出现，就是这个，那个成为了一系列，长跑者，人们的亲近。
Whenever I go speak at a college or play a gig somewhere, I'm always offered sandwiches by the kids.
每当我去大学演讲或在某个地方演出时，孩子们总是会给我三明治。
I say it's one of the most enduring things I hear about over and over and over again is the sandwiches thing.
我说，三明治是我一遍又一遍听到的最持久的事情之一。
So it was in this episode, high craze, it's so pure, it's like, okay, it's so pure.
所以在这一集中，高度狂热，它是如此纯粹，就像，好吧，它是如此纯粹。
It's so pure.
真是太纯粹了。
It's the storytelling thing, it's like he's telling the kids that and he forgot the name and like we really leaned into the like, the philosophical idea of this entire show that it is a story, it's not, it's an unreliable narrator in every sense of the word.
这是讲故事的事情，就像他在告诉孩子们，他忘记了名字，就像我们真的倾向于整个节目的哲学思想一样，它是一个故事，它不是，从任何意义上来说，它都是一个不可靠的叙述者。
I really love this one, I think this episode had a real outsized impact, it was really over performing, it has like a whole bunch of things that seem like they were from three or four episodes but it was just this one.
我真的很喜欢这一集，我认为这一集确实产生了巨大的影响，它真的表现得太过分了，它有一大堆看起来像是来自三四集的东西，但只是这一集。
Well, the gist is though that Ted has this new girlfriend and we do do a thing, Gloria, we call it old tech, but there's a kind of just, you know, anachronistic things that are like, Oh God, that we're like the online dating.
好吧，要点是，虽然泰德有了一个新女朋友，但我们确实做了一件事，格洛丽亚，我们称之为旧技术，但有一种，你知道，不合时宜的事情，就像，哦上帝，我们就像在线约会。
Yeah.
是的。
The online dating, like the shame of meeting someone on the high end month, that feels so old.
网上约会，就像在高端月份遇到某人的耻辱一样，感觉很古老。
That's so old.
那太老了。
That is old tech.
那是旧技术。
Yeah.
是的。
That is old tech.
那是旧技术。
And but I like, I forgot that it was a good motivator because it was like, blah blah doesn't like they're how we met story.
但我喜欢，我忘记了这是一个很好的激励因素，因为它就像，等等，不喜欢他们是我们相遇的故事。
It comes out how they really met and she's mortified.
得知他们是如何相遇的，她感到羞愧。
And then the group is like, no, no, we all had stupid flawed weird amazing stories.
然后大家就说，不，不，我们都有愚蠢、有缺陷、奇怪的惊人故事。
And then it kind of motivates why it's not just, they're sitting around for no reason saying all of this.
然后这有点激发了为什么他们不只是无缘无故地坐在那里说这一切。
We came up with a little bit of fuel.
我们想出了一点燃料。
There's like a reason why.
好像是有原因的
And it's sort of based on like the fact that everyone thinks she's a ticking time mom and they have to kind of talk her down.
这有点基于这样一个事实：每个人都认为她是一个时间紧迫的妈妈，他们必须说服她。
They know she's trouble.
他们知道她有麻烦。
And they have to make her feel a little better about it all cause she does seem like she might explode at any moment.
他们必须让她感觉好一点，因为她看起来确实随时可能爆炸。
She's very funny in this.
她在这方面非常有趣。
I will say, Pam and I, remember we talked about this while we were filming.
我会说，帕姆和我，记得我们在拍摄时讨论过这个。
The five of us together at the booth was a kind of formidable energy, I'd say, like it was a very intense, but I mean, I think, comedically, yes, it was unbelievable.
我们五个人一起在展位上，是一种强大的能量，我想说，就像是一种非常强烈的能量，但我的意思是，我认为，喜剧上，是的，这是令人难以置信的。
But it was also like, for a guest star, it could be intimidating, you know, all five of us.
但这也就像，对于客串明星来说，这可能会吓到我们五个人。
And definitely, around the booth, all series regulars.
当然，在展位周围，都是所有系列的常客。
And Abby Spencer came in and just like, she took over, she took over in a great way.
艾比·斯宾塞进来了，就像她接管了，她以一种很好的方式接管了。
I mean, that is a compliment.
我的意思是，这是一种恭维。
Yeah, she's formidable in and of herself in this episode.
是的，她在这一集里本身就很强大。
She's very funny.
她很有趣。
And she was somebody because the guys were so generous, you and Craig, you and Carter were so generous in letting me be the casting person in the room.
她之所以成为重要人物，是因为那些家伙非常慷慨，你和克雷格，你和卡特都非常慷慨地让我成为房间里的选角人员。
And I remember the first time we saw Ivy, I think she had read for something else.
我记得我们第一次见到艾薇时，我认为她正在阅读别的东西。
And we were like, oh, she's too good to like waste on a little Barney girl or a, you know, like, we really wanted to be saved her for this.
我们当时想，哦，她太好了，不喜欢浪费在一个小巴尼女孩身上，或者，你知道，就像，我们真的很想为此拯救她。
We didn't give her that.
我们没有给她那个。
I think she might have gotten very far for Victoria, actually.
事实上，我认为她可能已经为维多利亚走得很远了。
And we just watched her.
我们只是看着她。
And we were like, we've got to wait.
我们当时想，我们必须等待。
She's so beautiful and so funny.
她是如此美丽又如此有趣。
And she deserves a star turn and she got it in this, yeah.
她值得成为明星，她在这件事上做到了，是的。
Carter, I know, also saw, I did like one of those, I think 24-hour play.
卡特，我知道，也看到了，我确实喜欢其中之一，我想是24小时播放。
No, it was the young playwrights thing.
不，这是年轻剧作家的事。
You know, Carter used to be involved.
你知道，卡特曾经参与其中。
Yeah, and Abby was, and I were in the one together with Kat Foster.
是的，艾比是，我和凯特·福斯特也在其中。
Did you see that?
你看到了吗？
Yes, yes, I did.
是的，是的，我做到了。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
Because I remember, because that was before I think she was on the episode.
因为我记得，因为那是在我认为她出现在这一集之前。
Yeah.
是的。
We knew Abby for, yeah, and then years later, we dated, which is, you know, 15 years later, but it was funny.
是的，我们认识艾比，几年后，我们约会了，你知道，15 年后，但这很有趣。
I just have to say this that my wife and I, I'm married now, Gloria.
我只想说，我和我的妻子，我现在结婚了，格洛丽亚。
I have a six month old child, but we, we watched episode eight and episode five back to back just because of the wedding.
我有一个六个月大的孩子，但我们，因为婚礼，我们连续看了第八集和第五集。
This is good.
这很好。
Are you ready?
你准备好了吗？
Are you sitting down?
你坐下了吗？
This is the episode eight was my ex-girlfriend Lindsey Price, episode five, my ex-girlfriend Abby Spencer.
这是第八集是我的前女友林赛·普莱斯，第五集是我的前女友艾比·斯宾塞。
I'll be it with a 15 year gap in between them.
我会接受他们之间15年的差距。
But we watched them both and Jordana my wife got lover.
但我们都看了他们俩，我妻子乔丹娜有了情人。
It was like we're just this is a big day of watching your ex-girlfriend You know not every not every wife I think can hang with that No, what did that what did that feel you tell us paint us a word picture of but I mean you enter her it was strange I think but I think we'd have to get Jordana to come out of retirement.
就好像我们今天是看着你前女友的重要日子你知道不是每个我认为不是每个妻子都能忍受的不，那是什么感觉你告诉我们给我们描绘了一幅文字图​​片但我的意思是你进入了她，我认为这很奇怪但我认为我们必须让乔丹娜退出退休生活。
I know we need that anyway We're like good.
我知道无论如何我们都需要它，我们很好。
You're good.
你很厉害。
You guys survived it.
你们幸存下来了。
I mean, we're still.
我的意思是，我们还在。
We're still.
我们还在。
Yeah.
是的。
So I should say like we, because we recorded those two episodes today, they're not back to back episodes.
所以我应该像我们一样说，因为我们今天录制了这两集，它们不是背靠背的剧集。
Again, we had some scheduling stuff.
同样，我们有一些日程安排。
We needed to get glow here at a different time.
我们需要在不同的时间在这里焕发光彩。
And I watched both of them last night and I said, Rebecca, this is shaken out in a very strange way because I guarantee you, as we're sitting here on our couch watching these two episodes, Josh is with Jordana watching two episodes where Josh dated the two women And these two are literally the consecutive episodes, but there are only two women I significantly hated that.
我昨晚看了这两集，我说，丽贝卡，这是以一种非常奇怪的方式震动的，因为我向你保证，当我们坐在沙发上看这两集时，乔什和乔丹娜一起观看乔什与两个女人约会的两集，这两集实际上是连续的集，但只有两个女人是我非常讨厌的。
Right.
正确的。
And we had to watch them in the same night because we talked about those two episodes straight peeling back the curtain of how we make the podcast.
我们必须在同一晚观看它们，因为我们谈论了这两集，直接揭开了我们制作播客的帷幕。
Yeah.
是的。
I really didn't think of them were excellent.
我真的不认为他们有多优秀。
Great ladies.
伟大的女士们。
They were very talented.
他们非常有才华。
Yeah.
是的。
Great taste.
味道很棒。
Josh.
乔什。
Yeah.
是的。
I wrote you this little day to sing to you in New York City will be you right back.
今天我写信给你，是为了在纽约为你唱歌，你很快就会回来。
And now back to the show.
现在回到节目。
Hey, where did, uh, where did the hot crazy scale come from?
嘿，呃，那火爆的疯狂音阶是从哪里来的？
Do you guys remember that?
你们还记得吗？
I don't remember where it came from, you know, it's, I, I, the part of it that I remember what it comes from is there's, there's one detail in there where he calls it the Vicky Mendoza line.
我不记得它是从哪里来的，你知道，是，我，我，我记得它来自哪里，有一个细节，他称之为维姬·门多萨线。
It's this one.
就是这个。
The Mendoza line is a very famous thing in baseball, named after a baseball player, Mariam Mendoza.
门多萨线是棒球界非常有名的东西，以棒球运动员玛丽亚姆·门多萨的名字命名。
Mariam Mendoza.
玛丽雅姆·门多萨。
And it was the idea of, I think, the 200 batting average.
我认为这就是 200 次击球率的概念。
He was just the epitome of the guy who was right on the side of, is he still a useful player?
他只是那个站在一边的人的缩影，他还是一个有用的球员吗？
And is he probably good in the field?
他在这个领域可能表现出色吗？
He can kind of hit, and 200 was sort of the Mendoza line.
他可以击球，200 分是门多萨线。
I'm like, if you're any lower than that, and maybe you're not a solid infielder, you're in trouble.
我想，如果你的水平低于这个水平，而且也许你不是一名可靠的内野手，那么你就有麻烦了。
And so we just took that idea of the Mendoza and made it the freaky Mendoza line.
所以我们就采纳了门多萨的想法，并将其打造为怪异的门多萨系列。
But I was just so happy that Barney dated a Latina.
但我很高兴巴尼和一个拉丁裔约会。
I was like fine.
我很好。
Oh my God, it's so true.
天哪，这太真实了。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
We'd show you things.
我们会向你展示一些东西。
He's out there somewhere.
他在外面某个地方。
We never got to her.
我们从来没有联系过她。
We never should have.
我们永远不应该这样做。
Oh my God, that is so pretty low.
天哪，这水平太低了。
Do you know what really made me laugh was when she, when blah blah thinks that Barney and Robin are together and Robin goes on the nose, with the thing of like, he counted the note, like from the moment she started doing it.
你知道真正让我发笑的是，当她胡言乱语地认为巴尼和罗宾在一起时，罗宾就在鼻子上，用类似的东西，他数着音符，就像从她开始这样做的那一刻起。
It was different because Kobe was fucking with him and doing it and he's like, I'll just I was actually counting because we shot that I think four times.
这是不同的，因为科比正在和他做爱并这样做，他就像，我只是我实际上在数，因为我们投篮了四次。
I remember this.
我记得这个。
Yeah.
是的。
And every time she would fuck with him in a different way and he counted and it was right every single time.
每次她都会用不同的方式操他，他数着，每次都是对的。
Like one time it was like 24 and it was really high it was like so high that we couldn't use it.
就像有一次，它大约是 24，而且非常高，以至于我们无法使用它。
It was like 30 years.
好像有30年了。
I think.
我认为。
Yeah.
是的。
That's a little bit of like Neil as like comedic machine weird robot she could talk with him and and he would just be, and he was definitely counting.
这有点像尼尔，就像喜剧机器一样奇怪的机器人，她可以和他说话，而他就会这么做，而且他肯定在数数。
He's a, yeah, he had the comedy robot mind coming.
是的，他有喜剧机器人的头脑。
Unbelievable.
难以置信。
It was so funny.
太有趣了。
And then Lily got one in the end, and I think you also did it.
然后莉莉最终得到了一个，我想你也做到了。
I will say that the come on, Lily.
我会说，来吧，莉莉。
Come on.
快点。
That was funny.
这很有趣。
The three of those.
就那三个。
I could, that's also a top 10 favorite 10 moment for me, like comedy moment.
我可以，这也是我最喜欢的 10 个时刻，就像喜剧时刻一样。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
Because there was something funny about, he was both doing literally the exact same thing every time, and also like slightly deepening it like every time I try to push her into, I mean, yeah.
因为有一些有趣的事情，他每次都在做完全相同的事情，而且还喜欢稍微加深它，就像每次我试图将她推入一样，我的意思是，是的。
The cockiness and it was so good.
那种自负真是太好了。
So much of how I met your mother is about memory and nostalgia and the fallibility of memory and how like divergent narratives like this is a really narratives.
我遇见你母亲的大部分时间都是关于记忆、怀旧和记忆的错误，以及像这样不同的叙述是如何真正的叙述。
I mean, I really love the idea that Ted in Ted's mind, he's been carrying around a nuclear bomb piece of information and really has no fucking clue when he's talking about it.
我的意思是，我真的很喜欢泰德的想法，在泰德的脑海里，他一直带着核弹的信息，当他谈论它时真的一点线索也没有。
What a good friend.
多么好的朋友啊。
Yes.
是的。
I know.
我知道。
It's very juicy, like watching the episode again, I hadn't seen it in years.
真是太精彩了，好像又看了一遍，好几年没看了。
I was like, right.
我当时想，对吧。
This is a big deal.
这是一件大事。
10 million made up.
1000万弥补了。
Like I forgot for a second, like what the real story was.
就像我忘记了一秒钟，就像真实的故事是什么一样。
It's very juicy.
非常多汁。
It's where you definitely lean in as a viewer when you think that's real.
当您认为这是真实的时，您作为观众绝对会倾向于这样做。
There's a flaw guys because she still went to 110.
伙计们，这是有问题的，因为她还是拨打了110。
Right.
正确的。
Well, she still had the conversation with him where he had the cranberry juice cut.
好吧，她仍然和他交谈，他喝了蔓越莓汁。
I think they still had that conversation to talk about the ring.
我认为他们仍然有那次谈话来谈论戒指。
Yeah.
是的。
Yes.
By the way, Phil Lord, I forgot about that.
顺便说一句，菲尔·洛德，我忘了这一点。
I'm glad you brought.
我很高兴你带来了。
Yes.
是的。
That was an amazing thing.
那是一件了不起的事情。
We've.
我们有。
I totally forgot writer for look.
我完全忘记了作家的样子。
I know I forgot to because I was like, all right, Lily's going to be making out with a guy.
我知道我忘了，因为我想，好吧，莉莉要和一个男人亲热了。
And then boom, it's Phil Lord, we should say Phil Lord and Chris Miller, genius writer film makers.
然后繁荣，是菲尔·洛德，我们应该说菲尔·洛德和克里斯·米勒，天才作家电影制片人。
And now Oscar winning Oscar, you know, like, they literally have, they're incredible.
现在奥斯卡奖得主，你知道，他们确实获得了奥斯卡奖，他们太不可思议了。
They just in Project Hail Mary, they've done the Lego movies, they've done the Spider-Verse movies that are brilliant.
他们刚刚在万福玛丽计划中，他们制作了乐高电影，他们制作了精彩的蜘蛛侠电影。
They were on season one of him with you, Glow and with us.
他们在《他》的第一季中与你、Glow 和我们一起演出。
And they left at the end of season one because they were going to go direct their first feature, Cloudy with Chance Meatballs.
他们在第一季结束时离开，因为他们要执导他们的第一部长片《Cloudy with Chance Meatballs》。
And two years later, we had the scene to shoot.
两年后，我们有了要拍摄的场景。
And Allison was like, I don't know if I just want to have some random person that I don't know as the too much tongue guy in this memory and okay Alec I think we've queued up a nice little piece of audio from Memoryland.
艾莉森说，我不知道我是否只是想随机找一些我不认识的人作为这段记忆中太多舌头的家伙，好吧，亚历克，我想我们已经从记忆之地排队了一段不错的小音频。
Hey this is Phil Lord I have been asked to detail the story of my being cast I offer only as too much tongue guy didn't have to audition thank goodness it would have been Disrespectful to my stature as a a juice-paying SAG member I Chris and I were graciously let out of our contract to make cloudy with the chance of meatballs We had a long career killing television shows But with our presence and the the only show That we ever worked on that went more than one season was how I met your mother And so of course we quit in the middle just didn't feel right.
嘿，这是菲尔·罗德，我被要求详细讲述我被选为演员的故事，我提供的只是因为太多的舌头家伙不需要试镜，谢天谢地，这对我作为一名付费果汁的美国演员工会会员的地位是不尊重的，克里斯和我被慷慨地解除了我们的合同，以肉丸的机会变得多云我们有一个漫长的职业生涯杀死电视节目但是有了我们的存在和我们工作过的唯一一个持续超过一季的节目就是我如何认识你母亲的所以当然我们中途就退出了，只是感觉不太对劲。
Anyway, we wind up, we're directing our first animated movie thanks to the generosity of Carter and Craig and we got a very strange request from Gloria called it on Kellett who said, hey we want to do this This guy and Allison won't do it unless it's someone that she knows.
不管怎样，最后我们要导演我们的第一部动画电影，感谢卡特和克雷格的慷慨，我们收到了格洛丽亚提出的一个非常奇怪的请求，叫凯莱特，她说，嘿，我们想做这个，除非是她认识的人，否则这个人和艾莉森不会这样做。
And would you be down to, and don't take offense that we thought of you for this, but to play a character who kisses her very badly and disgusts her.
你会不会因为我们为此而想到你而感到生气，而是扮演一个吻得很厉害并且让她感到厌恶的角色。
I was like, she really just feels like you're the right person for the part.
我当时想，她真的觉得你是这个角色的合适人选。
So, you know, I listen, any attention is good attention, so I was happy to be a part of it.
所以，你知道，我听着，任何关注都是好的关注，所以我很高兴成为其中的一部分。
I don't remember much else.
其他的我不记得了。
I was unbelievably nervous.
我难以置信地紧张。
I remember on take two, I said, to Allison, I'm gonna lick your mouth.
我记得在第二次拍摄时，我对艾莉森说，我要舔你的嘴。
And I did, I licked her mouth like I was Marmaduke.
我做到了，我舔了舔她的嘴，就像我是马默杜克一样。
And I thought it was really funny, but it turned out it was just gross, and the audience, this is an important lesson for those of you out there producing comedy.
我觉得这真的很有趣，但事实证明这很恶心，观众们，这对那些制作喜剧的人来说是一个重要的教训。
Some things aren't just so repellent that the audience can't enjoy them.
有些东西并不只是令人厌恶以至于观众无法欣赏。
No matter how funny the writing might be, no one wanted to look at that.
无论文字多么有趣，都没有人愿意看。
So in the final episode, I think I'm on screen for like 12 frames before it cuts to black.
所以在最后一集中，我想我在屏幕上待了大约 12 帧，然后画面就变成黑色了。
Now it's quite, they couldn't have left us on doing our make-out sesh while the credits rolled or added a funny button, but it clearly did not merit that.
现在好了，他们不可能在片尾字幕滚动的时候让我们继续亲热，或者添加一个有趣的按钮，但这显然不值得。
And it was very clear in the moment as it was happening that this was not going to live.
事情发生的那一刻就非常清楚，这不会再存在了。
But anyway, I'm happy to be a part of it.
但无论如何，我很高兴能参与其中。
I love you guys, and I hope this car I'm in is not too noisy.
我爱你们，我希望我坐的这辆车不要太吵。
Oh, Phil.
哦，菲尔。
Yeah, Phil Lord, I feel it.
是的，菲尔·洛德，我感觉到了。
It's like, after that moment, I realized I was a director.
就好像，在那一刻之后，我意识到我是一名导演。
Yes.
是的。
Oh, my God.
我的天啊。
As soon as we, that came on the TV rewatching it, I was like, I got to ask Phil for his memory of like, yeah.
当我们在电视上重看它时，我想，我得问菲尔他的记忆，是的。
I feel like he's, I feel like he's missing a bet here.
我觉得他，我觉得他在这里错过了一个赌注。
I think Alison was like, Phil wasn't cute.
我认为艾莉森说，菲尔并不可爱。
I was like, I think it was much more flattering to Phil.
我当时想，我觉得这对菲尔来说更受宠若惊。
Yeah, did she suggest it or did we suggest it?
是的，是她建议的还是我们建议的？
Cause we thought it'd be fine.
因为我们以为这样就好了。
I don't remember either.
我也不记得了。
But I feel like whether or not she suggested it, she was like, yeah, Phil, I like Phil.
但我觉得无论她是否建议，她都会说，是的，菲尔，我喜欢菲尔。
And he's a cute guy.
他是一个可爱的人。
That's how I make out with him.
我和他就是这样相处的。
I think it was much more of a compliment than Phil.
我认为这比菲尔更多的是一种赞美。
And he was probably, you know, I remember those early years of cloudy with the chance and meatballs were tough.
他可能是，你知道，我记得早年的那些阴云密布的机会和肉丸很艰难。
He was probably like happy to have a couple of them.
他可能很高兴拥有他们两个。
Oh, yeah, I love being on how I met your mother and we loved having them.
哦，是的，我喜欢讲述我是如何认识你母亲的，我们也喜欢拥有他们。
It's, I'm so thrilled that they went and did what they did because they built the most brilliant career, but we missed them terribly.
我很高兴他们去做了他们所做的事情，因为他们建立了最辉煌的职业生涯，但我们非常想念他们。
They were great, but I remember we, we had our hundredth episode party for how much mother, hundredth episode party, and it was the same week that, or something like that, the cloudy with the chance of meatballs was coming out and Phil and Chris came to the hundred episode and him and party and they were like, congrats on a hundred episodes.
他们很棒，但我记得我们，我们为多少母亲举办了第一百集派对，第一百集派对，就在同一周，或者类似的事情，多云的肉丸即将出现，菲尔和克里斯来到了第一百集，他和派对，他们就像，恭喜一百集。
We just finished one movie since we left you.
离开你后我们刚刚看完一部电影。
that's how fucking logan takes to make an anime and we're like we did one movie and they have rest you made a hundred episodes um but it's an incredible movie it's an incredible movie it's an incredible movie i love that movie so much my kids watch movie over and over and over oh it's so good.
这就是他妈的洛根制作动画的方式，我们就像我们拍了一部电影，他们已经休息了，你拍了一百集，嗯，但这是一部令人难以置信的电影，这是一部令人难以置信的电影，这是一部令人难以置信的电影，我非常喜欢那部电影，我的孩子们一遍又一遍地看电影，哦，它太棒了。
they made a music.
他们创作了音乐。
they only make a good they oh yeah exactly they only make amazing things so i had to get Phil's take on that memory because he really had to waltzen two years after leaving the show waltzen and lick elson had against face in front of 50 people and he just fucking did it.
他们只会做出好的事情，哦，是的，他们只会做出令人惊奇的事情，所以我必须了解菲尔对那段记忆的看法，因为在离开演出两年后，他真的不得不跳华尔兹，华尔兹和利克·埃尔森在 50 人面前面对面，他他妈的就这么做了。
So great.
太棒了。
You know, it's also like, you know, college names, like, I remember, I mean, so it's, it's too much tongue guy and unreasonably small mouth, open girl, is that what it was?
你知道，它也像，你知道，大学名字，就像，我记得，我的意思是，所以它是，它的舌头太多了，嘴巴小得不合理，张开的女孩，是这样吗？
Yeah.
是的。
So we had a guy, I don't think anyone ever caught this guy's name at Kenyon College was a very small, and he was just called Birdman because he had a bird on his shoulder all the time.
所以我们有一个人，我认为在凯尼恩学院没有人知道这个人的名字非常小，他只是被称为鸟人，因为他的肩膀上一直有一只鸟。
He was Birdman.
他是鸟人。
In the dining hall.
食堂里。
Good branding.
良好的品牌宣传。
Yeah.
是的。
really funny.
真的很有趣。
Well, I think there's also, we're always looking, Gloria, for like, you know, what is the shorthand for friendship?
嗯，我想，格洛丽亚，我们一直在寻找，你知道，友谊的简写是什么？
I think you guys were so good at writing the way.
我认为你们写得很好。
And I think this is why it feels, even though it was, you know, brightly lit and had a sound, a laugh track, how I met your mother feels authentic because of touches like, yeah, that real nickname.
我想这就是为什么感觉很真实，尽管它是，你知道，灯火通明，有声音，有笑声，我如何遇见你母亲的感觉是真实的，因为像，是的，那个真正的昵称这样的触摸。
And GLOW, that was very you.
GLOW，那就是你。
That was all you, those names and that idea that you guys were unbelievable, unbelievably gracious.
这就是你们，那些名字和你们令人难以置信的、令人难以置信的亲切的想法。
I mean, the thing that people have to understand, we were so young.
我的意思是，人们必须理解的一件事是，我们太年轻了。
Like, it was my second Hollywood job.
就像，这是我的第二份好莱坞工作。
We were, you know, like Craig and I, we're both with our, are still with our people from, from, like.
你知道，我们就像克雷格和我一样，我们都和我们的人民在一起，现在仍然和我们的人民在一起。
You are Marshall and Lily.
你们是马歇尔和莉莉。
You are essentially Marshall and Lily too.
你们本质上也是马歇尔和莉莉。
You really are.
你确实是。
Yeah, we are.
是的，我们是。
We would always talk about like, you know, doing these dating stories and how like we're with this one person forever.
我们总是会谈论，你知道，做这些约会故事，以及我们如何永远和这个人在一起。
But like something that I really think was so important about the show and I really lament this moment is that it gave a language to what all of us were experiencing in the world at that time as young people, you know?
但就像我真正认为这部剧非常重要的一点，我真的为这一刻感到遗憾的是，它为我们所有人当时作为年轻人在世界上经历的事情提供了一种语言，你知道吗？
And there's not a show right now that does that for 25 years.
25 年来没有任何一部剧能做到这一点。
I agree, it's certainly not on a wide scale.
我同意，这当然不是大规模的。
Yeah, I think you're right.
是的，我认为你是对的。
There was friends for that time, then how I met your mother came and then like, where's the show right now that's documenting for people who laugh together, for people to like, I read a study like yesterday talking about how kids aren't dancing anymore because they're so terrified to be caught on tape.
那时有朋友，然后我是如何认识你母亲的，然后就像，现在有一个节目在记录人们在一起欢笑的情况，供人们喜欢，我读了一份像昨天一样的研究，谈论孩子们如何不再跳舞，因为他们非常害怕被录下来。
And the amount of fun that we got to do and mistakes that we got to make because they're just in our memory.
以及我们必须做的乐趣和我们必须犯的错误，因为它们只存在于我们的记忆中。
We don't have video footage of them and that was so potent about Ted telling these stories, you know?
我们没有他们的视频片段，但特德讲述这些故事是如此有力，你知道吗？
There's also something I imagine, and Craig and I have talked a little about this, like, you know, it's fun to write a genre piece or something.
还有一些我想象的东西，克雷格和我对此进行了一些讨论，就像，你知道，写一篇流派作品或其他东西很有趣。
But when you're writing about something that every aspect of your life is usable, like something that happened to you with your family or a bad date or whatever, and all of that can be spun into gold.
但当你写的东西是你生活的方方面面都可以利用的时候，比如你和家人发生的事情或者糟糕的约会等等，所有这些都可以变成金子。
You know, all your humiliations are.
你知道，你所有的羞辱都是。
Yeah, it's cool.
是的，这很酷。
By the way, the story, I mean, the story about blah, blah, blah, I forgot that some of that was based on that date that Ira had that was terrible.
顺便说一句，这个故事，我的意思是，关于废话、废话、废话的故事，我忘记了其中一些是基于艾拉的那个可怕的日期。
Do you remember that?
你还记得吗？
I do.
我愿意。
Yeah.
是的。
I, one of our writers from season one, I had a very, had an experience where he was sort of yelled at by, I don't even, it was, I don't even, it changed it apart.
我，我们第一季的编剧之一，我有过一次非常非常的经历，他被人大喊大叫，我什至不知道，是的，我什至不知道，它改变了它。
Was it a day, or was it a stage at a party was flirting with somebody?
是一天，还是聚会上与某人调情的舞台？
I was flirting at a K-Day.
我在 K 日调情。
We were K-Day's, R&P K-Day's, K-Day's, K-Day's, so hard, right down the street.
我们是 K-Day、R&P K-Day、K-Day、K-Day，太辛苦了，就在街上。
We were there, and there was a girl that somebody was trying to hook him up with, and they were kind of vibing.
我们在那里，有人试图勾搭一个女孩，他们的氛围很不错。
And I was sitting, I think I was sitting with Kobe actually and we were kind of watching this unfold and it started so promising and then went real hard.
我坐在那儿，我想我实际上是和科比坐在一起，我们正在观看这一切的展开，它开始时充满希望，然后变得非常艰难。
She really blah, blah, hard.
她真是废话，废话，很难。
She really liked.
她真的很喜欢。
Some of what she said is really what we had blah, blah, right?
她说的有些话确实是我们所说的废话，废话，对吗？
She hadn't done it.
她没有这么做。
I was like, I remade some jokes she didn't like and she freaked out and like said some really strange things about it's going to be my year and I'm designing handbags.
我当时想，我重述了一些她不喜欢的笑话，她吓坏了，说了一些非常奇怪的事情，今年将是我的一年，我正在设计手袋。
There was a stream.
有一条溪流。
On the Superstar, we were discovered that sometimes the most far-fetched sounding things on him, are things we just took verbatim from real life.
在《超级巨星》中，我们发现有时他身上听起来最牵强的东西，其实是我们从现实生活中逐字逐句获取的东西。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you, knew he looked city.
而这个老人，他一定让我爱上了你，知道他看起来像城里人。
And now, commercials.
现在，广告。
Hey, I'm Carl Radke.
嘿，我是卡尔·拉德克。
You might know me from Bravo's Summer House, but on my podcast, More Life, I get your favorite reality stars off the clock and into the conversations you don't usually get to hear.
您可能在 Bravo's Summer House 认识我，但在我的播客 More Life 中，我让您最喜欢的真人秀明星不分昼夜地参与到您通常听不到的对话中。
The deep stuff, the vulnerable stuff, the uncomfortable stuff.
深层的东西，脆弱的东西，不舒服的东西。
I've sat down with Ciara Miller, Derinda Medley, Tom Schwartz, Lindsey Hubbard, and a whole lot more.
我采访过 Ciara Miller、Derinda Medley、Tom Schwartz、Lindsey Hubbard 等人。
We get into relationships growing up, the messy stuff, and everything that happens when the cameras aren't rolling.
我们在成长过程中会陷入人际关系，遇到混乱的事情，以及摄像机不转动时发生的一切。
New episodes of more life every week, listen wherever you get your podcasts or watch on YouTube.
每周都有新剧集讲述更多生活，无论您在哪里收听播客或在 YouTube 上观看。
End of commercials, back to show.
广告结束，回到节目。
Well, I want to pay you a compliment too, because you are very, very good at mining your real life for stuff for him.
好吧，我也想称赞你，因为你非常非常善于挖掘你的现实生活为他找到东西。
And also, thank you for reminding me that you were my greatest ally of the Marshall and Lillie stories, because you and Dave are Marshall and Lillie too.
另外，谢谢你提醒我，你是我在马歇尔和莉莉故事中最伟大的盟友，因为你和戴夫也是马歇尔和莉莉。
You've been together since college, right?
你们从大学就在一起了，对吧？
College or right after college?
大学还是大学毕业后？
Oh, since 93, yeah.
哦，从93年开始，是的。
Right, so it was the same.
对啊，所以都是一样的。
It was the same.
都是一样的。
Yeah, same.
是的，一样。
We may be both met.
我们可能都会相遇。
I want it only.
我只想要它。
Yeah, I want it only.
是的，我只想要它。
But but but also I will say before I think we'll cut this out if this is bad in season one the idea of the drum roll Please the going to kiss but not quite kissing that was about a young love, but that wasn't Dave, right?
但是，但我还要说的是，如果第一季的情况不好的话，我们会删掉这个，鼓声的想法，请接吻，但不完全接吻，这是关于年轻的爱情，但这不是戴夫，对吧？
It was before Dave where you were just like it was you it was a fleeting moment and you said we can't really do anything We're gonna part ways.
在戴夫之前，你就像是你一样，那是一个转瞬即逝的时刻，你说我们真的无能为力，我们要分道扬镳了。
Yeah, that drum roll please.
是的，请打鼓。
He almost is which is another of Josh's top 10 episodes I think drum roll please the almost kissing that we we were talking about you and praising you when we were talking about that So we should have had you on for that one too.
他几乎是，这是乔什的前十集的另一集，我认为鼓声让我们在谈论你时几乎接吻，并在我们谈论那一集时赞扬你，所以我们也应该让你参加这一集。
I think we had Ashley Williams on that week.
我想那周我们有阿什利·威廉姆斯。
So we couldn't have you on there, but.
所以我们不能让你在那里，但是。
It was great, it was great.
太棒了，太棒了。
No, that was what I talked to you is what I talked to you.
不，这就是我和你说的。
But yeah, no, yeah, we did the drum roll all night because we were like, we can't, because it was like, you know, new love and you put so much, I don't eat.
但是，是的，不，是的，我们整晚都在敲鼓，因为我们想，我们不能，因为这就像，你知道，新的爱情，你放了这么多，我不吃。
That was, yeah, that was like, we were seeing it, Dave and I were seeing other people.
是的，就像我们正在看到它，戴夫和我正在看到其他人。
So it was technically out.
所以从技术上来说它已经过时了。
Okay, so that's why, okay.
好吧，所以这就是原因，好吧。
So that's why I'm making an edit it out if it's controversial.
因此，如果有争议，我会对其进行编辑。
No, no.
不，不。
It was technically allowed, but I had a hard time with it because I was like, no, I know I want to marry this guy and I feel bad, but we had this new thing, night in San Francisco, was the same.
从技术上来说这是允许的，但我很难接受，因为我想，不，我知道我想嫁给这个人，我感觉很糟糕，但我们有这个新事物，在旧金山的夜晚，是一样的。
I forgot the timeline of who was like, oh yeah, that said makes it even juicier.
我忘记了谁的时间表，哦，是的，这使得它更加有趣。
But you were very good about finding those juicy things from real life and putting it in your right.
但你很擅长从现实生活中找到那些有趣的东西，并将其放在你的权利之中。
Because I think like Ted, I mean, I wanted to create romantic moments too.
因为我想像特德一样，我的意思是，我也想创造浪漫的时刻。
I mean, it was such a force.
我的意思是，这是一种力量。
I mean, it's intense.
我的意思是，这很激烈。
The fact that he was like, okay, it's such an intense.
事实上，他就像，好吧，这太激烈了。
I think people think we made that up.
我认为人们认为这是我们编造的。
It's another thing we made it.
这是我们做到的另一件事。
It's like, no, Glow really had that.
就好像，不，Glow 确实有这样的东西。
You really had that night with somebody.
你真的和某人度过了那个夜晚。
But he was also like, that's not unlike Ethan Hawken, Julie Delpy being like, let's not exchange numbers.
但他也说，这和伊桑·霍肯没什么不同，朱莉·德尔佩也说，我们不要交换号码了。
Let's just meet back on this train platform at the very end.
我们就在终点站的这个站台见面吧。
By the way, I did run into him at a wedding years later.
顺便说一句，几年后我确实在一场婚礼上遇到了他。
No way.
决不。
At a wedding, no way.
婚礼上，没办法。
I did, I did.
我做到了，我做到了。
Well, because I went to visit this friend at UC Davis.
嗯，因为我去拜访了加州大学戴维斯分校的这位朋友。
That's how I met him.
我就是这样认识他的。
So I went up, we were running the weekend in San Francisco.
所以我就去了，我们周末在旧金山跑步。
Yeah, so we were like in each other's periphery.
是的，所以我们就像在彼此的边缘。
was deep at this wedding too?
这场婚礼也很深吗？
What?
什么？
It was complicated.
这很复杂。
It was very, yeah, it was really juicy.
是的，真的非常多汁。
It was great.
太棒了。
So as a writer, like, nothing's wasted.
所以作为一个作家，没有什么是浪费的。
Nothing's on the trail.
路上什么也没有。
It's all great.
一切都很棒。
When we talk about crime with some, I don't remember if you guys ever used it, Craig, but I remember one time you and I were actually, I think we'd had a day where they had come for us hard, where all the singles had come for us hard.
当我们和一些人谈论犯罪时，我不记得你们是否曾经使用过它，克雷格，但我记得有一次你和我实际上，我想我们有一天他们为我们而努力，所有单身人士都为我们而努力。
And we were like, we have more sex per capita than you have.
我们当时想，我们的人均性行为比你们多。
That's in there.
就在那里。
We just did that.
我们刚刚这么做了。
That was like two episodes before this one.
那就像这一集之前的两集。
Because this is episode five.
因为这是第五集。
And that was an episode two or three.
那是第二集或第三集。
We were like, no, no, we have, if you break it down, I remember, we were like, if you break it down.
我们就像，不，不，我们有，如果你打破它，我记得，我们就像，如果你打破它。
Marshall breaks it down.
马歇尔将其分解。
Yeah, you're 100% right.
是的，你是100%正确的。
There were probably two episodes ago that Marshall did that exact right.
可能在两集之前，马歇尔就做到了这一点。
And he calculated it and he broke it down.
他计算了它并把它分解了。
So I forgot.
所以我忘记了。
We didn't really, you broke it down in the room.
我们真的没有，你在房间里把它弄坏了。
You were like, no, we're making fun of us.
你说，不，我们在取笑我们。
You old, married, sad, pitiful, five, so we're like, no.
你老了，结婚了，悲伤，可怜，五岁，所以我们就像，不。
I would know if you're having good sex.
我想知道你的性爱是否顺利。
You've only had one penis.
你只有一根阴茎。
I'm like, take it easy.
我想，放轻松。
We have had consistency.
我们保持了一致性。
I think that's so funny that singles came for us.
我认为单身人士来找我们真是太有趣了。
We know, we know what works.
我们知道，我们知道什么有效。
I think we know what works.
我想我们知道什么是有效的。
We know what's going to get it done.
我们知道如何完成它。
We know what's going to get you where you want to go.
我们知道什么能让您到达您想去的地方。
Our 1000 hours have been put in.
我们已经投入了1000个小时。
We have the, we have the beat.
我们有，我们有节拍。
We were the Beatles in Germany.
我们是德国的披头士乐队。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
We got our hours and totally did covers and we were under the covers with a second up top, you know, we you were a good ally of like, and I'm actually been making a serious point, even though this is a great bit.
我们有时间，完全做掩护，我们在掩护下还有第二个上顶，你知道，我们是一个很好的盟友，我实际上一直在严肃地表达观点，尽管这有点伟大。
We you were a good ally in this early seasons of making sure there were Marshall and the least stories with me.
在这早期的几季里，我们是一个很好的盟友，确保有马歇尔和最少的故事发生在我身上。
You were really there with me, like we're the old Mary.
你真的和我在一起，就像我们是老玛丽一样。
That's what the fucking show like Ted is huge in the show, but Marshall and Lily that they're the fact that they're the old married couple at 27 is a big genetic piece of the show.
这就是像泰德这样的该死的节目在节目中的巨大之处，但马歇尔和莉莉他们是 27 岁的老夫妇这一事实是该节目的一个重要遗传部分。
And so I really appreciated that you were part of that voice of me because there weren't many others.
所以我真的很感激你是我声音的一部分，因为没有多少其他声音。
So that's honestly honestly and but what's funny is that in this episode there's this ostensibly really complicated reveal the Ted and Lily made out that's just completely wrong.
所以这是诚实的诚实，但有趣的是，在这一集中，有一个表面上非常复杂的揭露，泰德和莉莉发现这是完全错误的。
I love that we got to discover what really happened at the end and the tag in the flash forward, it mentions the mother, like there's so much in this episode.
我喜欢我们必须发现最后到底发生了什么，以及快闪中的标签，它提到了母亲，就像这一集中有很多东西一样。
This is just a call back though to the earlier point about you guys being the guardians kind of of Marshall and Lily.
这只是回顾之前关于你们是马歇尔和莉莉的监护人的观点。
When we had Greg Malen's on, he was saying, because he was a really big fan of the first season.
当我们穿上格雷格·马伦的时候，他说，因为他是第一季的忠实粉丝。
Did he come on season two or three?
他是在第二季还是第三季出现的？
He came in season two, but he was a fan of season one that he joined as an EP with us.
他参加了第二季，但他是第一季的粉丝，他作为 EP 加入了我们。
But he said, he always hated the sitcom trope of like the long time couple just being And he was like, I really like that you guys were writing a couple that had been together forever that really dug each other.
但他说，他总是讨厌情景喜剧中的比喻，就像一对长久以来的情侣一样，他说，我真的很喜欢你们写的是一对永远在一起、真正互相吸引的情侣。
Yes.
是的。
And Greg also has that in his life with his lovely wife.
格雷格和他可爱的妻子的生活中也有这样的经历。
He does.
他做到了。
Love who Jenny.
爱谁珍妮。
Yeah, Jenny.
是的，珍妮。
Yeah.
是的。
Exactly.
确切地。
It's nice to see that.
很高兴看到这一点。
It's nice to portray that and put that out in the world.
很高兴能够描绘出这一点并将其公诸于世。
The people actually like each other.
人们实际上互相喜欢。
It also made the show modern because, you know, we had been in rooms where that was not true.
这也让这场演出变得现代，因为，你知道，我们待过的房间并非如此。
That was not true.
那不是真的。
We're the men.
我们是男人。
You'll bow and chain.
你会弓和锁链。
Yeah, you don't.
是的，你不知道。
They did not enjoy their wives.
他们不喜欢他们的妻子。
They were like, let's stay here because we don't want to go home.
他们说，我们留在这里吧，因为我们不想回家。
Whatever that was in various scenarios, which we saw.
无论我们看到的各种场景是什么。
And it was so nice that we genuinely really liked our spouses.
这真是太好了，我们真的很喜欢我们的配偶。
Yeah.
是的。
And you guys were great also about letting us go home.
你们也很高兴让我们回家。
I think for those that don't know, sitcom rooms can go very late.
我想对于那些不知道的人来说，情景喜剧室可能会很晚。
And Carter and Craig were so great about like, no, we need you to come back with stories.
卡特和克雷格非常擅长，不，我们需要你带着故事回来。
So like go live life.
所以喜欢去生活。
Yeah.
是的。
Come back up.
回来吧。
Absolutely.
绝对地。
Sarah Silverman in her book, The Bedwetter talks about, you can tell if a showrunner has a happy marriage or not by how late they'll be.
莎拉·西尔弗曼（Sarah Silverman）在她的书《尿床者》中谈到，你可以通过节目主持人迟到的时间来判断他的婚姻是否幸福。
What the hours are?
几点钟？
No, it can become a real hostage situation in me and on the wedding staff.
不，这可能会成为我和婚礼工作人员真正的人质情况。
We're just like, he's not letting us go home.
我们就像，他不让我们回家。
And how will you live life, right?
你将如何生活，对吗？
How will you bring stories in?
你将如何把故事带进来？
And how will you go help those crazy moments and those like whatever's happening?
你将如何帮助那些疯狂的时刻和那些正在发生的事情？
You need to be living life and mining your own life.
你需要享受生活并挖掘自己的生活。
And I think we had a very, and I glow, I imagine as a showrunner, which you've done now for years since how much mother, you become a sure owner on your own right.
我认为我们有一个非常，我发光，我想象作为一个节目主持人，你已经这样做了很多年，因为多少母亲，你凭借自己的权利成为了一个确定的主人。
You, I imagine you have a confessional safe room.
你，我想你有一个忏悔室。
You want writers to feel like this is a very safe space.
你希望作家觉得这是一个非常安全的空间。
We can be very honest in here.
我们在这里可以非常诚实。
You really get to know each other.
你们真的互相了解了。
I imagine that's your aesthetic as well.
我想这也是你的审美观。
Cause that's, you were so, that was your energy in our room.
因为你就是这样，这就是你在我们房间里的能量。
Did you feel Gloria that you learned the kind of room you wanted to run was like based on how I met your mother?
格洛丽亚你有没有觉得，你是根据我和你母亲的见面方式了解到你想要经营的房间是什么样的？
Yeah.
是的。
Definitely.
确实。
Well, the guys were so generous.
嗯，伙计们真是太慷慨了。
They were so generous about letting us, Like, I got to sit in editing with Sue.
他们非常慷慨地让我们，比如，我可以和苏一起编辑。
I got to say, you know, like, that was not the case with a lot of these spaces.
我不得不说，你知道，很多这样的空间并非如此。
And- So crazy.
而且-太疯狂了。
That's so easy.
那太容易了。
They had casting, they would send you down to casting.
他们有选角，他们会把你派去选角。
I would do casting, they let me do casting.
我会做选角，他们让我做选角。
They let me, like, they really allowed us to produce our episodes.
他们让我，就像，他们真的允许我们制作我们的剧集。
And it's wild because now, part of what we're also seeing is, you know, my last show, I had producer level writers who had never been on a set.
这很疯狂，因为现在我们所看到的一部分是，你知道，在我的上一场演出中，我有从未参加过片场的制片人级别的编剧。
Right?
正确的？
Because it's a stingy thing of we, they want to stop paying the writers once production starts, which is like fucking And Saint Josh and I've talked about that a lot on this podcast of just like, the writers bonding with Josh, you guys becoming friends and, and understand each other's energies makes you a better writer for Josh and Josh, the better actor of your words.
因为这对我们来说是一件小气的事情，一旦制作开始，他们就想停止付钱给编剧，这就像他妈的，圣乔什和我在这个播客上谈了很多，就像，编剧和乔什建立了联系，你们成为朋友，并且了解彼此的能量让你成为乔什和乔什的更好的作家，你的话更好的演员。
And Melon's insists that the writers have to know the cast, like on a deeply personal level.
Melon 坚持认为编剧必须了解演员阵容，就像在个人层面上一样。
No, Hollywood is fucking that up now.
不，好莱坞现在已经搞砸了。
You would bring stuff, you know, I was so close to Kobe, I remember like the literally thing came because she was literally doing that all the time.
你会带来一些东西，你知道，我和科比非常接近，我记得就像字面上的东西来了，因为她实际上一直在这样做。
I was trying to remember if that was from real life.
我试图记住那是否来自现实生活。
That is stupid.
那是愚蠢的。
Oh, yeah, that's real life.
哦，是的，这就是现实生活。
Oh, that's real life.
哦，这就是现实生活。
And she was aware that we were taking that from real life.
她知道我们正在从现实生活中汲取这一点。
I knew I bought her doing that, dude.
我知道我买了她这样做，伙计。
It does feel true, but oh my god, that's really funny.
这感觉确实是真的，但是天哪，这真的很有趣。
Yeah.
是的。
But you got to know each other.
但你们必须互相了解。
That's the whole point.
这就是重点。
And you feel that in the show.
你在节目中也能感受到这一点。
You feel that energy.
你感受到那种能量。
And you're like one of Kobe's best friends, I would say.
我想说，你就像科比最好的朋友之一。
You guys are like dear to your friends.
你们就像亲爱的朋友一样。
I was.
我是。
I know.
我知道。
You know what, not yay, because I love it.
你知道吗，不是的，因为我喜欢它。
Because it would be her if it didn't be her.
因为如果不是她，那就是她。
And you, but just understanding each other as a creative team, this idea that that's not happening.
而你，只是作为一个创意团队相互理解，这种想法并没有发生。
And I'm so glad that the Writers Guild has tried to fight for that and tried to make the case that that's important.
我很高兴作家协会一直在努力争取这一点，并试图证明这一点很重要。
And the fact that that's even a battle shows how little the money side of the equation does not understand the creative, the creative alchemy.
事实上，这甚至是一场战斗，这表明金钱方面是多么不了解创意和创意炼金术。
Yeah, we're not with the makers.
是的，我们不和制造商在一起。
I think like shows like this that are like classics.
我认为像这样的节目就像经典一样。
I think that what was also really interesting is I think that we were all acutely aware at the time that we were making something that would last.
我认为真正有趣的是我认为我们当时都敏锐地意识到我们正在制作一些能够持久的东西。
I felt that for sure.
我确信这一点。
Were you really?
你真的是吗？
I felt that with the pilot.
我和飞行员一起感受到了这一点。
Yeah.
是的。
That's really true coming in because you know, when you're when you're staffing guys, what happens is, well, there used to be a staffing season.
这确实是真的，因为你知道，当你为员工配备人员时，会发生的事情是，嗯，曾经有一个人员配备季节。
Do you remember that?
你还记得吗？
I know.
我知道。
list, but there used to be a season where you would go, you'd read the script, you'd meet with the showrunner, and then you'd get to sit in a room alone and watch the show before sitting in, so that you could sit like a couple of minutes.
名单，但曾经有一季你会去，你会读剧本，你会见节目主持人，然后你会独自坐在一个房间里看节目，然后再坐下来，这样你就可以坐几分钟。
I'm like VHS 10.
我就像 VHS 10。
Yeah.
是的。
How did VHS do?
VHS 表现如何？
Absolutely.
绝对地。
And you get to watch it.
你可以观看它。
And I remember being like, oh my god, they made a romantic comedy in 22 minutes.
我记得我当时想，天哪，他们在 22 分钟内拍出了一部浪漫喜剧。
How did they do that?
他们是怎么做到的？
And so it was just so special and such a like specific voice and all the quick cuts.
所以它是如此特别，如此独特的声音和所有的快速剪辑。
and all that, it was just like, no one had done that thing.
所有这一切，就像没有人做过那件事一样。
And if you go to so many of those meetings and you see, you have the privilege of seeing a lot of different pilots, ones that go in, ones that don't, you know.
如果你参加了很多这样的会议，你会发现，你有幸看到很多不同的试点，有些参加了，有些没有参加，你知道。
And there was something just so special, and then there was something so special about, you know, you and Carter and how gracious you guys were to all of us, how ever, there was no, I was the lowest level writer in that room.
有一些非常特别的东西，然后有一些非常特别的东西，你知道，你和卡特，以及你们对我们所有人的仁慈，然而，没有，我是那个房间里水平最低的作家。
It was my second job.
这是我的第二份工作。
And you guys always made us all feel like we were the same.
你们总是让我们都觉得我们是一样的。
Like every idea here matters, even our wonderful writers assistants, many of whom got to also staff on the show like it was a it was a really such a special place.
就像这里的每个想法都很重要一样，即使是我们出色的编剧助理，他们中的许多人也在节目中担任工作人员，就像这真的是一个非常特别的地方。
It was almost like in some ways I think you're in Carter's youth like really served you because one you were you couldn't believe you'd been given this and also like you didn't know enough to be dicks like you didn't you weren't cynical right like and you were really yeah I think I my experience of it was almost a blend of what Gloria is saying, I felt like if they gave us time, we were gonna like write one for the ages, we were gonna make a show that really was a classic in which we ended up doing.
这几乎就像在某些方面，我认为你在卡特的青年时代真的为你服务，因为你不敢相信你被赋予了这个，而且你也没有足够的了解成为一个混蛋，就像你没有愤世嫉俗一样，你真的是的，我想我的经历几乎融合了格洛丽亚所说的，我觉得如果他们给我们时间，我们会喜欢写一个永恒的，我们会制作一个真正是一个节目我们最终所做的经典。
But also at the same time, and I don't know if you remember this as acutely as we did, Gloria, but like we were on a season-to-season maybe basis.
但同时，我不知道你是否像我们一样清楚地记得这一点，格洛丽亚，但就像我们可能是在一个赛季又一个赛季的基础上一样。
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
Something happened, it might have been the end of third season, we got a two-season pickup.
发生了一些事情，可能是第三季结束了，我们得到了一个两季的皮卡。
It was either the end of fourth season I think it was end of fourth, I think it was end of fourth.
那要么是第四季的结尾，我想是第四季的结尾，要么是第四季的结尾。
Did Britney Spears save the show?
布兰妮·斯皮尔斯拯救了这部剧吗？
This is the question.
这就是问题所在。
I mean, it is definitely part of it and we're about to, we're right there.
我的意思是，这绝对是其中的一部分，我们即将做到，我们就在那里。
We're getting up.
我们要起床了。
That's a few episodes away.
距离还有几集了。
It was the first time I felt like we got national press, right?
这是我第一次感觉到我们得到了全国媒体的关注，对吧？
Like, yeah, yeah.
就像，是啊，是啊。
It changed things.
它改变了一切。
I'm making all the time ever that stun casting worked.
我一直都在让眩晕施法发挥作用。
It's so true.
这是真的。
It usually, it's just like, okay, that's a blip.
通常，这就像，好吧，这只是一个昙花一现。
And then it goes back down.
然后它又回落。
It did seem to elevate the entire enterprise somehow.
它似乎确实在某种程度上提升了整个企业的水平。
It made us seem like you had to keep your eye on the show or something.
这让我们觉得你必须密切关注节目或其他东西。
It did, it helped a lot.
确实如此，很有帮助。
Well, it helped her and it helped us.
嗯，这对她有帮助，对我们也有帮助。
It was mutually beneficial.
这是互惠互利的。
Yeah, that was crazy.
是的，那太疯狂了。
You were there, and this was a weird season, just looking ahead a little bit.
你在那里，这是一个奇怪的季节，只是向前看一点。
The writer's guilt strike happened.
作家的愧疚罢工发生了。
Remember, just all of a sudden we just had to stop.
请记住，突然间我们不得不停下来。
No, I was pregnant.
不，我怀孕了。
I was pregnant.
我怀孕了。
You were right on the day, shot.
那天你是对的，开枪了。
I went into labor at how I met your mother and Craig Gerard drove me home.
我在遇见你母亲时就开始临产了，克雷格·杰拉德开车送我回家。
I got that glow.
我得到了那种光芒。
Goddamn it towards the end of the scene.
该死的，在场景的最后。
I went into labor.
我开始临产了。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
I was, and Craig, you specifically were so nervous.
我和克雷格，你特别紧张。
You're like, cause I would have fractions, and you're like, get out of here.
你会说，因为我会有分数，而你会说，离开这里。
And I'm like, Craig, this could be, it could be 24 hours of this, it's fine.
我想，克雷格，这可能是，这可能是 24 小时，没关系。
And I was like, you can't sit there and you have to go home.
我当时想，你不能坐在那里，你必须回家。
You have to do it, get out of here.
你必须这么做，离开这里。
And finally, they were like four minutes apart, and Craig drove you.
最后，他们相隔大约四分钟，克雷格开车送你。
You're like, I know how to get this show, press a set baby.
你就像，我知道如何获得这个节目，按设定宝贝。
Oh my God, that's right, you were very pregnant by the end of the night.
天啊，没错，那天晚上你就怀孕了。
I was very pregnant, yeah.
我怀孕了，是的。
That's crazy.
太疯狂了。
So when this episode was being shot and you were on set, you were however many months pregnant, probably a little, and that, you know, cause I think that, the story you just told is the end of season three.
所以当这一集拍摄时，你在片场，你已经怀孕几个月了，可能只有一点点，你知道，因为我认为，你刚才讲的故事是第三季的结尾。
Yeah, like toward the end of season three.
是的，就像第三季快结束时一样。
That was like near the end is when you had the baby, I feel like it was, yeah, I feel like it was very much.
就像快要结束的时候，当你生下孩子的时候，我觉得，是的，我觉得这非常多。
Like we had maybe even finished shooting and yeah, we're right at the end.
就像我们可能已经完成拍摄一样，是的，我们就在最后。
That's crazy.
太疯狂了。
That's right.
这是正确的。
And then he's now going to college.
然后他现在要去上大学了。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
Jesus.
耶稣。
We're getting too old.
我们已经太老了。
That's amazing.
太棒了。
You know what I love about this episode also?
你也知道我喜欢这一集的什么吗？
I feel like, do you know friends like you know, like you remember the first time you saw a 13 year old friend, a 16 year old friend, like when you met.
我觉得，你认识的朋友像你认识的那样，就像你记得第一次见到13岁的朋友、16岁的朋友，就像你们见面时一样。
And how emblage, if they stay in your life, it becomes, I don't know, like almost like biblical, like the origin story of how you met.
如果他们留在你的生活中，我不知道，它会变得多么像圣经里的那样，就像你们相遇的起源故事一样。
And I feel like part of the fondness that these fans have for these characters are, they get to see them in all weather and at different ages, college-led, high school-led, college-wide early.
我觉得这些粉丝对这些角色的喜爱部分在于，他们可以在各种天气、不同年龄段、大学主导、高中主导、全大学范围内很早就看到他们。
You're all over the timeline in this episode.
您已经完成了本集中的时间线。
There's a lot of years touched upon, including the future.
涉及了很多年，包括未来。
Can we not talk about 2020?
能不能不谈2020年了？
Can we talk about 2020?
我们可以谈谈2020年吗？
We need to talk about 2020.
我们需要谈谈2020年。
So they're in a college reunion, and the Chiron comes as it says 2020, the tag.
他们正在参加一次大学聚会，而 Chiron 的出现正如标签上写的“2020”。
We would just flash forward to 2020, college union, no masks anywhere.
我们会快进到2020年，大学工会，任何地方都没有口罩。
They're clearly out of vaccine deniers and COVID deniers.
他们显然不再否认疫苗和新冠病毒。
It's funny that Wesleyan of all schools be like, no masks required.
有趣的是，所有学校中卫斯理学院都不需要戴口罩。
No mask required.
无需戴口罩。
Wesleyan getting it very wrong, very un-politically correct.
卫斯理安的做法非常错误，非常不政治正确。
It was so, I laughed out loud when I came up and said 2020 is like, little did we know.
事情就是这样，当我上来说 2020 年就像我们所知甚少时，我大声笑了起来。
Also, how old we thought we would be.
另外，我们认为自己会有多大。
Oh my God, right?
天啊，对吧？
Jason's 100 years old.
杰森已经 100 岁了。
Allison has like a Betty White wig on or like Allison looks like Geraldine Ferraro.
艾莉森戴着像贝蒂·怀特一样的假发，或者艾莉森看起来像杰拉尔丁·费拉罗。
That is a deep cut reference right there.
这是一个深刻的参考。
Not everyone's gonna get that one.
不是每个人都会得到那个。
So, Glow, this was obnoxious young us, like 30 years old, like, ha, these guys are gonna be their 40s.
所以，Glow，这对我们这些年轻人来说是令人讨厌的，比如 30 岁，就像，哈，这些家伙将是 40 多岁。
Let's make them look a fucking 100 years old.
让我们让他们看起来他妈的有100岁了。
And Josh may keep on coming up against us because we did this a bunch of times, these flash fours and they look a billion years old.
乔什可能会继续与我们对抗，因为我们已经做过很多次了，这些闪光的四人组，它们看起来有十亿年的历史了。
And we're now older than they are a lot of that time.
我们现在比他们年纪大很多。
And I'm just like cursing out past us, you and me and all of us, all of us writers like, You thought you were so fucking hilarious, didn't you?
我就像在咒骂我们，你和我，我们所有人，我们所有的作家，就像，你以为你他妈的很搞笑，不是吗？
So funny.
太有趣了。
50-year-olds looked like the cryptkeeper.
50 岁的人看起来就像是密码保管人。
It's, yeah, we really went overboard with that, but it is a very funny tag.
是的，我们确实做得太过分了，但这是一个非常有趣的标签。
It's 2020, it's college unions are in May.
现在是 2020 年，五月是大学工会。
I have a quote from my wife, I wrote down.
我写下了我妻子的一句话。
They're 42, they look like they're 65.
他们42岁，看起来像65岁。
That's what she says.
她就是这么说的。
Jason looks definitely mid-60s.
杰森看起来绝对是 60 多岁。
I don't know what in God's name we were thinking of doing.
我不知道看在上帝的份上我们想做什么。
It looks like he's about to retire from the Supreme Court.
看起来他即将从最高法院退休。
It's also kind of doing a physical thing, like you can't really walk.
这也是一种身体上的事情，就像你不能真正走路一样。
We're so young as we're making that, that we're so obnoxious about, quote, old people who are 42.
我们做这件事的时候还太年轻，以至于我们对 42 岁的老人感到非常讨厌。
It's really unacceptable.
实在令人难以接受。
Yeah.
是的。
You know what is, I've been, this has been pointed out to me over the years, but I love them having sandwiches by the vending machines at the end.
你知道是什么，多年来一直有人向我指出这一点，但我喜欢他们最后在自动售货机旁吃三明治。
Yeah, I love that scene.
是的，我喜欢那个场景。
It's really sweet.
真的很甜。
Also, when Ted starts laughing at the end, where's my wife?
另外，当特德最后开始大笑时，我的妻子在哪里？
Where's my wife?
我的妻子在哪里？
He's the whole show.
他是整个节目的主角。
It's the whole show.
这是整个节目。
He sums up the entire show.
他总结了整个节目。
It's a throwaway stony line.
这是一条一次性的石线。
Yeah, but it's the whole show in one line.
是的，但整场演出都在一条线上。
It's like the DNA in one little cell of like what's, yeah, like I know.
它就像一个小细胞中的 DNA，是的，就像我所知道的那样。
It's like prismatic.
它就像棱柱形的。
Like the whole is contained in the part.
就像整体包含在部分中一样。
Yes.
是的。
I love that.
我喜欢那个。
I know me too.
我也认识我。
I find it so moving.
我觉得很感动。
It's very moving.
非常感人。
And I also remember, sometimes you just, I see these scenes and I remember, oh, that was fun.
我还记得，有时你只是，我看到这些场景，我记得，哦，那很有趣。
Like, I remember sitting on the ground, eating sandwiches with Jason and Allie and just having a blast.
就像，我记得坐在地上，和杰森和艾莉一起吃三明治，玩得很开心。
Like the kind of like, I can't believe this is my job kind of days.
就像那种喜欢，我不敢相信这就是我工作的日子。
Yeah.
是的。
It feels that way.
感觉就是这样。
That seems feels that way.
似乎是这样的感觉。
It feels very loose and very fun and very real.
感觉很松散，很有趣，也很真实。
Like we're getting this wonderful little glimpse.
就像我们看到了这美妙的一瞥。
They're all still friends in the future.
未来他们仍然是朋友。
Ted's wife is definitely there.
特德的妻子肯定在那里。
We're just she's off camera somewhere.
我们只是她不在镜头之外的某个地方。
It's very exciting.
这非常令人兴奋。
I also felt like we knew the moment sandwiches landed in our laps.
我还觉得当三明治落在我们腿上的那一刻我们就知道了。
Like we knew we had a bit.
就像我们知道我们有一点一样。
We had a good bit.
我们过得很愉快。
I think that's a carter-based bit.
我认为这是基于卡特的一点。
And you knew that it was not going to be the last time you see.
而且你知道这不会是你最后一次见面。
Yeah, sandwiches was pretty recurring.
是的，三明治很常见。
It's it's a great.
这真是太棒了。
It's one of the top five things I hear most about is sandwiches.
我最常听到的五种食物之一就是三明治。
And if you meet someone in their 20s, they'll be like, ah, it's we'd smoke, we had some sandwiches and like every time they reference, they that's the go to him, you reference a couple questions or observation.
如果你遇到一个 20 多岁的人，他们会说，啊，我们抽烟，我们吃了一些三明治，就像每次他们提到的那样，他们就是去找他，你提到几个问题或观察。
I really made me laugh when Barney turns to Ted in the bathroom says, I like you Ted.
当巴尼在浴室里转向泰德说：“我喜欢你，泰德”时，我真的笑了。
Like for some reason, he just gets it in his head.
就像出于某种原因，他只是把它记在脑子里。
Like I'm going to I'm going to use my way into this guy's life.
就像我要做的那样，我要用我的方式进入这个人的生活。
This is the guy.
这就是那个家伙。
This is a guy.
这是一个家伙。
Yeah, it's in a way that's like that's the one for Barney.
是的，从某种程度上来说，这就是巴尼的风格。
Yeah, Barney has met his one.
是的，巴尼遇到了他的那个人。
We have a running thing on this podcast, Gloria, where I'm pretty sure that how I met your mother had weird prophetic qualities without realizing it.
我们在这个播客上有一个正在运行的节目，格洛丽亚，我很确定我是如何遇见你母亲的，具有奇怪的预言性，但我却没有意识到。
Except about COVID.
除了关于新冠病毒的事情。
It missed a very big one, but it got some smaller ones.
它错过了一个很大的，但它得到了一些较小的。
Okay.
好的。
In 2007, Robin has a run about subprime mortgages that was before the 2008 crash.
2007 年，罗宾在 2008 年金融危机之前就发起了一场关于次级抵押贷款的挤兑。
Yeah, we discovered that which I thought was pretty extraordinary early also Talking Barney talking about Ted's tiny lady like hands.
是的，我们很早就发现了这一点，我认为这非常不寻常，而且会说话的巴尼也在谈论特德那双像淑女一样的小手。
I think really prophesies Trump Yes, I mean look a lot about Barney's world.
我认为真的预言了特朗普是的，我的意思是多看看巴尼的世界。
Yeah There were two these two apps back to back not only had ex-girlfriends of mine, but both had sign language Yes, yes, they both had something which and Alec why don't you pop in Alec Lev who one of his many Alec, Alec is a man of many talents.
是的，这两个应用程序背靠背有两个，不仅有我的前女友，而且都有手语是的，是的，他们都有一些东西，亚历克为什么不让亚历克·列夫（Alec Lev）出现，他是他的众多亚历克之一，亚历克是一个多才多艺的人。
He's a Renaissance man.
他是一位文艺复兴时期的人。
He is a very highly skilled sign language interpreter, has interpreted for Paul McCartney concert, has interpreted for Barack Obama.
他是一位技术非常高超的手语翻译，曾为保罗·麦卡特尼的演唱会做过翻译，也为巴拉克·奥巴马做过翻译。
Am I lying, Alec?
我在撒谎吗，亚历克？
All in the street, right?
都在街上吧？
You are not lying.
你没有说谎。
And is the go to when we need a sign language on how much your mother, we would call Alex before Alec even worked on the show, right?
当我们需要手语告诉你妈妈多少钱时，我们会在亚历克参与节目之前打电话给亚历克斯，对吗？
This is before you were doing like digital and DVD and new media stuff.
这是在你从事数字、DVD 和新媒体业务之前。
This is season three.
这是第三季。
And we called upon you twice, right, and quick succession to do ASL, right?
我们两次请你做 ASL，对吗？
You probably taught Josh.
你可能教过乔什。
And it was all with me, I think I was always the signer.
这一切都与我有关，我想我一直是签名者。
That's right, I had done a couple of the behind the scenes features in season two, Carl had hired me to do that, to do a couple of making of bits, also in season three.
是的，我在第二季中做了一些幕后工作，卡尔雇我来做这件事，在第三季中也做了一些制作。
But then yes, I was hired for a couple of dollars to be your sign language consultant on both of those episodes.
但是，是的，我被聘请为这两集的手语顾问，花费了几美元。
The production is okay, your sign production's okay.
制作没问题，你的标牌制作没问题。
It got the job done.
它完成了工作。
Yeah, he got us where we wanted to go.
是的，他带我们去我们想去的地方。
Ted will get you where you need to go.
泰德会带你去你需要去的地方。
That line, though, from Kobe Ted is very good.
不过，科比·特德的这句话非常好。
I'm sure he will get you where he needs you.
我相信他会带你去他需要你的地方。
That makes me laugh so much.
这让我笑得很厉害。
And that's all we're looking for.
这就是我们要寻找的一切。
Where the Shelly Gillespie Zone come from?
雪莉·吉莱斯皮区从何而来？
Shelly Gillespie was a girl that was mean to me in grade school.
雪莉·吉莱斯皮（Shelly Gillespie）是一个在小学时对我很刻薄的女孩。
Oh, my God.
我的天啊。
You always came up with good names.
你总是想出好名字。
Oh, I did it.
哦，我做到了。
I got the Alexa, what's my college roommate?
我有 Alexa，我的大学室友是什么？
And I remember that that was a real name.
我记得那是真名。
It's a great name.
这是一个伟大的名字。
Alexa, he was delighted.
亚历克斯，他很高兴。
I asked her, I did not ask Shelly.
我问她，我没有问雪莉。
Of course, it's not only, your history is not only useful for plot devices, also for revenge.
当然，不仅如此，你的历史不仅对情节设计有用，对复仇也有用。
Exactly.
确切地。
For revenge.
为了复仇。
For sweet, sweet revenge.
为了甜蜜、甜蜜的复仇。
Yeah, take that Shelly Gillespie.
是的，就拿雪莉·吉莱斯皮来说吧。
I like when Ted says I cut it with cranberry juice because it was pretty strong.
我喜欢特德说我用酸果蔓汁切它，因为它非常浓。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
It's a pinot noir.
这是黑皮诺。
I cut it with green red juice.
我用绿红汁切它。
I cut it with a glass of wine.
我用一杯酒切它。
It's so delicious.
真是太好吃了。
It's so good.
太好了。
It's with his spectacles and the glass of wine.
这是他的眼镜和一杯酒。
There was always the one guy, the glass of wine.
总是只有一个人，一杯酒。
Look at these peasants around me, but he put cranberry juice in it.
你看我身边这些农民，他却往里面放了蔓越莓汁。
It's good.
很好。
We really cover a lot of ground in this episode.
我们在这一集里确实涵盖了很多内容。
A lot of years.
很多年了。
It's a very flashy, forwardy-backy episode.
这是一个非常华丽、前卫的剧集。
I do remember really loving doing the crying phone called a Karen.
我确实记得非常喜欢打电话叫凯伦的哭泣电话。
Yes, and quoting Descartes and then saying I sent you an electronic man electronic I went to the campus center and sent you an electronic mail which is what you had to do you had to do yeah because Dave was at Notre Dame when I was a freshman 17 minutes it would take oh my god yeah now I remember walking to get there you had to walk to send an electronic mail I sent you You had to go to the place.
是的，引用笛卡尔的话，然后说我给你发了一个电子人电子，我去了校园中心，给你发了一封电子邮件，这是你必须做的事情，你必须做是的，因为戴夫在巴黎圣母院，当我还是一名新生时，需要 17 分钟，天哪，是的，现在我记得步行到那里，你必须步行才能发送我发给你的电子邮件，你必须去那个地方。
College Ted is so is just nonstop home runs.
大学特德就是这样，不停地打出全垒打。
College Ted does not think so.
学院特德不这么认为。
You're so good.
你真好。
It's so, you have, you can see you having fun with that.
是这样的，你可以看到你从中获得乐趣。
Was it a Riva Deertre Fierro where he came on kind of as college Ted?
是一辆 Riva Deertre Fierro 吗？他的造型有点像大学时期的 Ted？
I think that was, because that was their big road trip home.
我想是的，因为那是他们回家的长途旅行。
That was, my parents live in Ohio.
也就是说，我的父母住在俄亥俄州。
I live in the moment.
我活在当下。
Yes, that was, that was the big entrance.
是的，那就是，那就是大入口。
And I was like, we're going to keep going back to this.
我当时想，我们会继续讨论这个问题。
And he was such a reliable world to go to.
他是一个值得去的可靠的世界。
I love when, I think it's, wait, who says, is it Ted or Marshall who says he's gonna use force?
我喜欢，我想，等等，谁说，是特德还是马歇尔说他要使用武力？
Cause that sounds wrong.
因为这听起来不对。
That sounds right.
听起来不错。
It's Broda.
是布罗达。
I'm gonna use the force to get a girl.
我要用武力去追女孩
That's what you give in Barney shit.
这就是你给巴尼的屎。
Yes.
是的。
Which is a great speed.
这是一个很棒的速度。
I love that bit.
我喜欢这一点。
The lily Marshall and him doing his laundry for the next two weeks.
莉莉·马歇尔和他在接下来的两周里洗衣服。
That man is a God.
那个人是神。
Yeah.
是的。
It's great seeing Barney lose.
很高兴看到巴尼输了。
You need to see Barney when we talk about this a lot.
当我们经常谈论这个问题时，你需要见见巴尼。
He needs to get duped.
他需要被欺骗。
Yeah.
是的。
He needs Barney needs no.
他需要巴尼不需要。
He needs a regular come up and to balance the scales of justice.
他需要定期出现并平衡正义的天平。
Oh, yeah, it's a pain.
哦，是的，这是一个痛苦。
We know where it came from.
我们知道它从哪里来。
It all as it does with some of the time.
这一切就像某些时候的情况一样。
He's so sociopathic and evil that you're like, wait a minute.
他是如此的反社会和邪恶，以至于你会说，等一下。
Well, you wrote another one where we peeled back the layers.
好吧，你又写了一篇，我们剥开了层层。
And season to the showdown episode where we went and Bob Barker's his dad.
到了决战那一集，我们去那里，鲍勃·巴克是他的父亲。
But not really we that was the beginning of really excavating until like Barney's carrying some real baggage here Like there's a reason he's the way he is and that was that was an important well those guys aren't listen the man is here The man is fear needs to be a you know dismantled and it's those guys were in pain they're in deep in I know exactly and they've all put on their little suits of armor Like Barney has a literal suit of suiteness, but it's like there's a scars underneath there And some of my proudest things about Barney on the series are when we dug into that and Showdown was a great early example.
但其实我们并不是真正挖掘的开始，直到像巴尼在这里背负着一些真正的包袱一样，他之所以这样是有原因的，那是一个重要的原因，那些家伙没有听他在这里，这个人需要被拆除，你知道，那些家伙正处于痛苦之中，他们深陷其中，我确切地知道，他们都穿上了他们的小盔甲，就像巴尼有一套真正的套装，但这就像那里有伤疤，关于巴尼在这个系列中我最自豪的一些事情是当我们深入研究这一点时，《摊牌》就是一个很好的早期例子。
I mean, in season one, also we did the sort of how Barney became Barney episode.
我的意思是，在第一季中，我们也做了巴尼如何成为巴尼的那一集。
Remember that's where the Darth Vader thing, that was kind of the predecessor to Showdown.
请记住，这就是达斯·维德的故事，它是《决战》的前身。
And like each season we found new things.
就像每一季一样，我们都会发现新的东西。
And I think that's really important.
我认为这非常重要。
You guys were always alert to what was fueling that was like pain and abandonment.
你们总是对诸如痛苦和遗弃之类的助长因素保持警惕。
Like, yeah, you were never trying to be like.
就像，是的，你从来没有试图成为那样。
Well, I would say that's another prophetic hymnium thing because look where we are.
好吧，我想说这是另一件预言性的赞美诗，因为看看我们现在所处的位置。
It's like, we're so in that right now.
就好像，我们现在就陷入了这样的境地。
It's ridiculous if we could just take into that.
如果我们能考虑到这一点，那就太荒谬了。
Oh, correct, this is actually a good segue.
哦，对了，这实际上是一个很好的转场。
I was telling, Gloria, I was telling him that in a first season radio tour, I don't know if you remember, we had to do these radio tours.
我告诉格洛丽亚，我告诉他，在第一季的广播巡演中，我不知道你是否还记得，我们必须进行这些广播巡演。
We'd get up early in the morning.
我们早上很早就起床了。
And they patch you through to like 12 or 15 radio stations around the country to interview you for five minutes about how I made your mother.
他们会给你转接全国 12 或 15 个广播电台，对你进行五分钟采访，了解我是如何造就你母亲的。
And I was on with like, I don't know, like mad dog and jungle Pete or something like, you know?
我和我在一起，我不知道，就像疯狗和丛林皮特之类的，你知道吗？
And I was new to the whole publicity game, and it was only first season, and it's 6.30 in the morning, right?
我对整个宣传游戏都是新手，而且这只是第一季，而且现在是早上 6.30，对吧？
The coffee's barely hitting.
咖啡几乎没喝到。
And this guy says to me.
这家伙对我说。
Yeah, so Josh Radder, we were watching the show, and we both think that your show needs more cool characters, like Neil Patrick Harris, and less faggie ones like yours.
是的，所以乔什·拉德（Josh Radder），我们正在观看这部剧，我们都认为你的剧需要更多酷的角色，比如尼尔·帕特里克·哈里斯（Neil Patrick Harris），而不是像你这样的肥胖角色。
No way.
决不。
And I was really alive.
而我真的还活着。
Are you live?
你还活着吗？
You're live on the air?
你在直播吗？
And I was stunned into silence like I literally like I didn't know what I don't think you ever told me that story That's disgusting.
我惊呆了，陷入了沉默，就像我真的不知道什么一样，我认为你从来没有告诉过我那个故事，这太恶心了。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, I told my publicist who I'd only been with for five minutes, right?
是的，我告诉我的公关人员我只和他在一起五分钟，对吧？
I was like, yeah, I'm never talking I should do not book me for shows like this or these guys ever again.
我当时想，是的，我从来没有说过我不应该再为我预订这样的节目或这些人。
Yes, like I was really upset about it.
是的，就像我对此感到非常沮丧一样。
Oh, yeah But then that's the kind of thing that made me insecure about like The part and the you know what I mean?
哦，是的，但是这就是让我对这个部分缺乏安全感的事情，你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah, yeah boy Those guys are not the target audience for the show.
是的，是的，这些家伙不是该节目的目标观众。
That is not who we're writing that show for.
我们不是为那些人写这部剧的。
And also, if you don't understand that Barney was this huge parody of that kind of masculine behavior and not an endorsement of it, it never was.
而且，如果你不明白巴尼是对这种男性行为的巨大模仿，而不是对其的认可，那么它从来就不是。
Yes.
是的。
And some people really got that and some people really didn't get that and here we are.
有些人确实明白了这一点，而有些人确实没有明白这一点，而我们就在这里。
But I can't believe I didn't even tell you that story for some reason.
但我不敢相信，出于某种原因我什至没有告诉你这个故事。
I've never heard you tell the story.
我从来没有听你讲过这个故事。
That's insane.
那太疯狂了。
That's disgusting, that's a bummer.
这太恶心了，太无耻了。
I'm sorry, you had to go straight to that.
抱歉，你必须直接说。
There is some weird stuff when you're out there promoting things.
当你出去推销东西时，会发生一些奇怪的事情。
There's some weird stuff, right?
有一些奇怪的东西，对吧？
People will ask you, even the writers, the card man I had some experiences where people would ask questions that were so aggressive and strange and mean.
人们会问你，甚至是作家、卡片人。我有过一些经历，人们会问一些非常激进、奇怪和刻薄的问题。
And then you realize, not everyone is watching the same show.
然后你意识到，并不是每个人都在看同一场节目。
Like everyone's watching their own show.
就像每个人都在看自己的节目一样。
I did write down too much tongue guy unreasonably small-mouth opening girl worst superheroes ever.
我确实写下了太多舌头家伙不合理的小嘴张开女孩有史以来最糟糕的超级英雄。
Hello, by the way, I looked up this episode on Hemium Wiki, that is really funny.
你好，顺便说一句，我在 Hemium Wiki 上查到了这一集，这真的很有趣。
I looked up Hemium Wiki, they made the point that in drumroll, please, Victoria says to Ted, I don't know if we should kiss because then we won't have a great memory.
我查了一下 Hemium Wiki，他们在鼓声中指出，拜托，维多利亚对特德说，我不知道我们是否应该接吻，因为那样我们就不会有美好的记忆。
What if you do this, or what if I do this, or what if you use too much tongue and it's a real motif and you're, there's a too much tongue to feel.
如果你这样做怎么办，或者如果我这样做怎么办，或者如果你用太多舌头而这是一个真正的主题怎么办，而你有太多的舌头感觉不到。
Yes.
是的。
No, there is a perfect amount.
不，有一个完美的数量。
It's true.
这是真的。
It's my agenda.
这是我的议程。
I got it out there.
我把它拿出来了。
You know, I didn't have a memory.
你知道，我没有记忆。
I did have a memory about the tag.
我确实有关于标签的记忆。
The actress playing Alexa.
饰演 Alexa 的女演员。
I had to show her how to do the Ted, come on, like I had to demonstrate that because she wasn't there when we shot the other side.
我必须向她展示如何做特德，来吧，就像我必须演示这一点，因为当我们射击另一边时她不在那里。
Yeah, it had to be a perfect mirror, right?
是的，它一定是一面完美的镜子，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
And she was funny.
她很有趣。
That really worked.
这确实有效。
She was great.
她很棒。
And like Ted.
就像特德一样。
No.
不。
It's a perfect ending.
这是一个完美的结局。
It's a great, it's a great, it's a great episode, Glo.
这是一个伟大的，这是一个伟大的，这是一个伟大的插曲，格洛。
Bravo.
太棒了。
Bravo, Loria.
太棒了，洛丽亚。
It's a really good one.
这真是一件好事。
It's a group effort as we all know.
众所周知，这是一项集体努力。
And we had great, we had great shining light beacon of light.
我们有伟大的，我们有伟大的闪亮的灯塔。
Was it fun to rewatch it all these years later, Glo?
格洛，这么多年后重看这部电影很有趣吗？
So fun.
太有趣了。
Oh, so fun.
哦，真有趣。
Yeah.
是的。
It's such a good time.
这真是一个美好的时光。
It was so, because we were all that age.
之所以如此，是因为我们都到了那个年纪了。
And it was, you know, really fun to remember.
你知道，回忆起来真的很有趣。
Like we laughed all day and told stories.
就像我们整天笑、讲故事一样。
and like you said, Josh, it made going through traumatic times much more bearable because of the therapy of getting to share it with the room, making people laugh, putting it out into the show, and then having people see it be seen.
就像你说的，乔什，它让经历创伤时期变得更容易忍受，因为与房间分享它，让人们发笑，把它放到节目中，然后让人们看到它是一种治疗方法。
I mean, it's, you know, when people come up and talk about various things I've done, I'm always, I'm so proud that this show broke my career.
我的意思是，你知道，当人们出现并谈论我所做的各种事情时，我总是为这部剧破坏了我的职业生涯而感到自豪。
I mean, it made me, it really, it really changed the course of my career.
我的意思是，它让我，真的，真的改变了我的职业生涯。
And I'm so grateful that I got to be there for whatever 64 episodes or whatever.
我很感激我能参加 64 集之类的节目。
It strikes me when you say we were that age, making the show about people that age.
当你说我们在那个年龄段，制作关于那个年龄段的人的节目时，我感到很震惊。
And I think like, if you look at a show like another memory show, like the Wonder Years, that was clearly people older looking back on the time.
我认为，如果你看一个像另一个记忆节目一样的节目，比如《奇迹岁月》，那显然是年长的人回顾那个时代。
This show is about someone older looking back on a time.
这个节目是关于一个年纪较大的人回顾过去的故事。
But none of us were writing it.
但我们没有人写它。
were in the time they were living in the past and they were imagining the future rather than the reverse.
他们生活在过去，想象着未来，而不是相反。
Yes, that's right.
是的，没错。
And it changes it.
它改变了它。
It changes the feeling.
它改变了感觉。
But by the way, I don't remember.
但顺便说一句，我不记得了。
I'm so impressed by Ted's memory.
特德的记忆力给我留下了深刻的印象。
I know, even though I'm a little loud boy.
我知道，尽管我是个有点吵闹的男孩。
He remembers so much more than we do now at this age.
他的记忆力比我们这个年纪的人还要多。
What we keep asking the question is, what we're seeing Ted's version of it or are we seeing the real story and Ted is telling?
我们一直在问的问题是，我们看到的是特德的版本，还是我们看到的是特德讲述的真实故事？
Do you know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
Oh yeah, I think it's Ted's version now.
哦，是的，我想现在是特德的版本了。
I feel like I just ate a sandwich from this question.
我觉得我刚刚吃了一个三明治。
I feel so high right now.
我现在感觉很高。
What if we're all just existing with an intense room?
如果我们都住在一个紧张的房间里怎么办？
It's just we're gonna keep unpacking this.
只是我们要继续拆开这个。
So romantic.
太浪漫了。
It's still romantic.
还是很浪漫的。
The story is so romantic and it's seen through this lovely lens of let's also say a good man.
这个故事是如此浪漫，而且是通过这个可爱的镜头看到的，我们也可以说是一个好男人。
I think that like we struggle right now to find good men on TV and this is a show about somebody who's legitimately looking And for his life partner, it's so pure and really sweet and like, he's a good guy doing his best and making mistakes along the way.
我认为，就像我们现在在电视上努力寻找好男人一样，这是一个关于一个正在合法寻找的人的节目，对于他的生活伴侣来说，它是如此纯洁，非常甜蜜，就像，他是一个尽自己最大努力并一路犯错误的好人。
And that's something we don't get to see very much anymore in a comical way.
我们再也不会以滑稽的方式看到这种情况了。
And I think it's not a surprise that people are still so drawn to the show so many years later.
我认为多年后人们仍然对这部剧如此着迷并不奇怪。
That's what makes a show classic is really decent people doing their best and we get to laugh along.
这就是这部剧之所以成为经典的原因，那就是真正正派的人们尽了最大努力，我们也能一起开怀大笑。
Welcome back to the show.
欢迎回到节目。
We're wrapping things up for today.
我们今天的事情就这样结束了。
We've had such a good time talking to our friend Gloria Calderon-Kellett.
我们和朋友格洛丽亚·卡尔德隆-凯利特交谈得很愉快。
Gloria, what a treat to see you and hear from you and just spend this time together.
格洛丽亚，见到你、听到你的消息、一起度过这段时间真是一种享受。
Thank you so much for being here.
非常感谢您来到这里。
Likewise.
同样地。
Yeah.
是的。
As we like to do in what we call the C-block.
正如我们喜欢在 C 区所做的那样。
I don't know why we do that, we just do it.
我不知道我们为什么要这么做，我们就是这么做。
Thank you for coming in.
谢谢您的光临。
ASMR.
ASMR。
We like, that's right.
我们喜欢，就对了。
That's right.
这是正确的。
If people use this to fall asleep, I hope that that knocks them out.
如果人们用它来入睡，我希望这能让他们昏过去。
But we like to read at the beginning of the show.
但我们喜欢在节目开始时阅读。
We obviously like to play a voice note from fans.
我们显然喜欢播放粉丝的语音留言。
And at the end of the show, we like to read a note that we've received.
在节目结束时，我们想读一下我们收到的一张便条。
If you would like to write us or record a voice note, please go to how we made your mother.com H-W-M-Y-M.
如果您想给我们写信或录制语音留言，请访问我们如何制作您的 mother.com H-W-M-Y-M。
Go to contact, follow the directions.
前往联系方式，按照指示进行操作。
Very easy.
很容易。
This is our favorite thing to hear from you guys.
这是我们最喜欢从你们那里听到的事情。
What the show means to you, you know, anecdotes about your life, how the show has affected you, how it changed things for you.
这个节目对你意味着什么，你知道，关于你生活的轶事，这个节目如何影响你，它如何改变你的事情。
Let us know.
让我们知道。
That's part of this whole thing, it's here.
这是整个事情的一部分，就在这里。
So, Glow is going to be our guest reader.
因此，Glow 将成为我们的客座读者。
guest reader for this week.
本周的客座读者。
So take it away, Gloria.
所以把它拿走吧，格洛丽亚。
Very exciting.
非常令人兴奋。
Okay.
好的。
This comes from Jane from Honolulu, Aloha.
这是来自檀香山的简，阿罗哈。
I just came across your podcast the last couple of weeks and have already finished the first season.
我最近几周才看到你的播客，并且已经完成了第一季。
It's making me feel very nostalgic.
这让我感到非常怀旧。
Although I must have watched your show when it first came out, my fond memories are of watching it a few years later with my two young sons, starting when they were probably four and six years old.
虽然我一定在你的节目第一次播出时就看过了，但我美好的回忆是几年后和我的两个年幼的儿子一起观看的，从他们可能四岁和六岁的时候开始。
As a full-time working mom with a 40 to 60 minute commute to the kid's school and my office, the end of the day was exhausting.
作为一名全职妈妈，每天要花 40 到 60 分钟通勤才能到达孩子的学校和我的办公室，一天结束时我感到筋疲力尽。
After some time an hour in traffic, it was shuffling kids and all their things into the house, making dinner while helping with homework, washing dishes, and cleaning up.
经过一个小时的交通堵塞后，孩子们和他们所有的东西都拖着进屋，一边做晚饭，一边帮忙做作业、洗碗和打扫卫生。
Then the three of us would plop down on the couch and watch how I met your mother.
然后我们三个人就会扑通一声坐在沙发上，看我是如何认识你母亲的。
They were too young to understand all the jokes.
他们还太小，无法理解所有的笑话。
Yes, but they loved the show anyway.
是的，但无论如何他们都很喜欢这个节目。
and I love how time slowed down while we watched.
我喜欢我们观看时时间变慢的感觉。
With my youngest sitting snuggly in my lap and my oldest cuddled up next to me, it was my half hour of adult time that the kids took part in.
我最小的孩子舒服地坐在我的腿上，最大的孩子依偎在我旁边，孩子们参与了我的半小时成人时间。
After the show was over, the TV would go off and it was back to racing around for bath time, teeth brushing, books before bed and settling down.
演出结束后，电视就会关闭，人们又开始忙着洗澡、刷牙、睡前读书，然后安顿下来。
Watching the show, there were probably a few times where I had to cover their eyes, but for the most part, it gave me the chance to explain things like, Bernie is showing how not to be.
看节目时，可能有几次我不得不遮住他们的眼睛，但在大多数情况下，这让我有机会解释诸如“伯尼正在展示如何不这样做”之类的事情。
I was pleased when my friend said, he wanted to be just like Marshall and Lily when he.
当我的朋友说他想成为像马歇尔和莉莉那样的人时，我很高兴。
As they got older, we continued to watch on the couch, sometimes binge watching during a rainstorm or a sick day.
随着他们年龄的增长，我们继续在沙发上观看，有时在暴雨或生病的日子里狂看。
Soon they were teenagers who came and went, so I would sit on the couch and watch an episode or two by myself.
很快他们就变成了来来往往的青少年，所以我会坐在沙发上自己看一两集。
In passing, they'd often ask, which one I was watching and all I'd have to say was a word or phrase like snowstorm or boats, boats, boats, and they'd know, I mean, sometimes if we were bored, I'd say, give me two numbers, and they'd randomly pick two numbers.
顺便说一句，他们经常会问，我在看哪一个，我只需说一个词或短语，比如暴风雪或船、船、船，他们就会知道，我的意思是，有时如果我们感到无聊，我会说，给我两个数字，他们会随机选择两个数字。
First one for season, the second one for episode, and we'd watch that episode together now.
第一季的第一集，第二集的剧集，我们现在会一起观看这一集。
You would be a good one.
你会是一个好人。
Now my oldest is away on the mainland at college, and I'm starting to feel the dread of an empty nest.
现在我的大儿子远赴大陆上大学，我开始感受到空巢的恐惧。
My youngest is not so young anymore, but will sit and watch with me as a happy palate cleanser after watching something scary or dark before bed.
我最小的孩子不再那么年轻了，但在睡前看了一些恐怖或黑暗的东西后，他会坐在我身边，作为快乐的味觉清洁剂。
My oldest recently texted me a photo of himself in a suit for a kid who grew up in Hawaii.
我最大的孩子最近给我发了一张他穿着西装的照片，照片上是一个在夏威夷长大的孩子。
It's not something you see before making a presentation.
这不是您在进行演示之前看到的东西。
And I had this sincerest pleasure of texting back, you suit it up.
我很高兴能回复短信，你适合吧。
I will forever equate how I met your mother with the feeling of sitting with my boys, laughing together, sometimes crying together and being present with each other to enjoy 20 minutes of stillness.
我将永远把我与你母亲的相遇等同于和我的孩子们坐在一起，一起笑，有时一起哭，彼此在一起享受 20 分钟宁静的感觉。
I was lucky to have many of these moments throughout their childhood where I could marvel the observations of a five-year-old and then nine-year-old, then a teenager with some shows sparking conversation and some inspiring contemplation.
我很幸运，在他们的童年时期经历了很多这样的时刻，我可以惊叹一个五岁孩子、然后是九岁孩子、然后是一个十几岁孩子的观察，其中一些节目引发了对话和一些鼓舞人心的沉思。
I'm hopeful that when both my kids are fully grown adults and I'm an wrinkly old woman, I'll be able to call or text them wherever they are and say, zitch dog or thank you Linus or suit up.
我希望，当我的两个孩子都长大成人，而我是一个满脸皱纹的老妇人时，无论他们身在何处，我都能够给他们打电话或发短信说，“zitch dogs”或者“谢谢你，Linus”或者穿好衣服。
And they'll know exactly what I mean.
他们会确切地明白我的意思。
Oh my gosh, wow.
天哪，哇。
That's really moving.
这真是令人感动。
I find that very moving because that letter covers like the huge span of time in and of itself.
我觉得这非常令人感动，因为这封信本身就涵盖了漫长的时间跨度。
She took us on a journey.
她带我们去旅行。
That was really well done.
那确实做得很好。
That was a great letter.
那是一封很棒的信。
Thank you.
谢谢。
I feel the weight of the journey there.
我感受到了那里旅程的沉重。
I love him Yem Roolette.
我爱他耶姆·鲁莱特。
Like just call it out.
就像直接喊出来一样。
Just call it out and just let in the face to side.
只要喊出来，然后让脸转向侧面即可。
That's fantastic.
太棒了。
I love that.
我喜欢那个。
I also just, you know, kind of what we're doing, like growing older with a piece of art, you know, kind of alongside you.
我也只是，你知道，我们正在做的事情，就像随着一件艺术品一起变老，你知道，有点像在你身边。
And as an access point to bond with your kids, My son watches the show with us occasionally, also far too young, six people, I don't think he should be watching it.
作为与孩子建立联系的一个切入点，我儿子偶尔会和我们一起看这个节目，他也太小了，六个人，我认为他不应该看。
But he does, when I talk, he kind of his attention drifts.
但他确实如此，当我说话时，他的注意力有点转移。
He knows that voice.
他认识那个声音。
That's very cool.
太酷了。
Yeah, that's very cool.
是的，那太酷了。
Which is funny because I remember the reason they wouldn't let me do the narrators because they thought my voice didn't sound old enough.
这很有趣，因为我记得他们不让我担任旁白的原因是因为他们认为我的声音听起来不够老。
It's crazy.
太疯狂了。
But I think my voice sounds somewhat similar to how it sounded.
但我觉得我的声音听起来和听起来有些相似。
Your voice sounds exactly the same.
你的声音听起来一模一样。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, well, that was a lovely letter.
是的，那是一封可爱的信。
Thank you so much and thank you to Gloria for being here.
非常感谢你们，也感谢格洛丽亚来到这里。
Thank you, Glo.
谢谢你，格洛。
Just wonderful to see you and what a great episode, how we met everyone else.
很高兴见到你，这是多么精彩的一集，我们是如何认识其他人的。
And we'll see you next time.
我们下次再见。
How We Made Your Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并执行制作。
and it's presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
它由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 呈现和分发。
The show is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey, and the show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev.
该节目还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛担任执行制作人，由我亚历克·列夫制作和编辑。
Our co-producer is Doug Matika.
我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves, Appointed Blue Studios, and our Gen Z Masters, our digital content producer Emily Blumberg, and associate producer, Katherine Grove.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Blue Studios 指定的 Alex Reeves，我们的 Z 世代大师、我们的数字内容制作人 Emily Blumberg 以及副制作人 Katherine Grove。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help to spread the word.
它确实有助于传播信息。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《New York City》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Sam Theobold and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢 Sam Theobold 和 Elliot Connors。
Go to HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，然后单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Our stories and questions are an important part of the show.
我们的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack, and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的 Muse Letters，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐和其他所有内容。
Order Craig Thomas's debut novel, That's Not How It Happened, Wherever Books Are Sold, and read his other published writing at CraigThomasRider.com.
订购 Craig Thomas 的处女作《That's Not How It Happened》、Wherever Books Are Sold，并在 CraigThomasRider.com 上阅读他出版的其他作品。
And you could subscribe to my own Dead Father Society on Substack.
你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的亡父协会。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise funds for congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解您如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。